tensorflow can do some amazing things
when it comes to computer vision in this
course machine learning engineer noor
islam muktari will teach you how to
create multiple computer vision projects
using tensorflow 2. hello and welcome to
my course introduction to tensorflow for
computer vision
so just a quick introduction about
myself
my name is noor islam
i work as a machine learning engineer
and i'll be your instructor for this
course
if you have any questions regarding the
course material and content or anything
related to machine learning and computer
vision feel free to connect with me on
linkedin and twitter
and if you're starting a career in
machine learning and computer vision
then please check out my free ml job
ready checklist that i have put together
which contains some information that
might help you to set a roadmap for
things you should learn and maybe things
that the machine learning and computer
vision industries might expect from you
so all of these information regarding my
social media accounts and also this free
checklist can be found in the link below
it's one link but it's gonna show you
all of the necessary information once
you click it
let's take a look at the course outline
[Music]
so
we're going to start the course by doing
some software setup
then i'm going to show you how to do
image classification using mnist dataset
which is basically the equivalent of the
hello world
examples in the machine learning field
then we're going to look at the image
classification using german traffic
science which is a real world data set
that reflects more challenges compared
to the mnist dataset
so for the software setup we're going to
start by
downloading and installing visual studio
code
i'm also going to show you how to get
miniconda i'm going to tell you why we
need it and how to install it
we're gonna be
using minicanda with vs code so i'm
gonna show you how to make those two
work together
then we're gonna install tensorflow 2
cpu and gpu versions we're also gonna be
installing different python packages
along the way
for the second part
which is the amnest example we're gonna
basically explore the amnest data set
i'm going to show you how to build a
function that
randomly looks into the data set and it
gives you some ideas about how this
dataset is constructed
i'm also going to show you how to use
tensorflow layers how to import them and
how to use them to build the neural
network we're going to be building the
same neural network architecture in
three different ways which are the ways
supported by tensorflow
so the first one is called the
sequential way by using the sequential
class the second
approach is called the functional way
which is basically your model is wrapped
inside a function
and the third approach is the model
class way which is by inheriting from
the model class we then
gonna do the compilation of the model
and we're gonna fit the amnes data set
into our model we're gonna finish this
part of the course by restructuring our
code for better readability which is
something you're going to find yourself
often doing when working on machine
learning projects in the industry
and for the last part of the course
we're going to be working with the
german traffic signs data set which is a
real world data set that reflects the
real challenges when working on machine
learning projects
compared to prepared data sets like the
amnest dataset
so for this we're going to start by
downloading and exploring the data set
we're going to prepare the training
validation and the test sets because
they're not already prepared
we're going to build our neural network
we're going to create some data
generators which is a different approach
than the one we
will be using for the first example
which is the amnesty example we're going
to compile the model and fit the data
i'm also going to show you how to add
some callbacks and why they could be
very useful
and i'm going to show you how to
evaluate your model using the generators
you created before
then i'm gonna show you some potential
improvements that you can do to get even
better results
and we're gonna finish this uh
part of the course and basically the
whole course by
a an example of how you would use your
model to make prediction on single
images so basically how to build a
standalone example that can make or that
can use your model in order to make uh
separate predictions
so
who is this course for
basically this course is for anyone
who's interested in learning about
tensorflow specifically for computer
vision applications
ideally you should have good knowledge
about python
like
classes and functions in python and also
basic concepts in deep learning such as
convolutional layers
so why would you learn tensorflow anyway
well there are several reasons but these
are three of
the main reasons in my opinion
so tensorflow is the leading framework
in deep learning followed by pytorch
and you can build powerful deep learning
solutions with it for your own use and
also for your company the company you're
working for
and there are lots of companies working
on deep learning projects and they are
using tensorflow so the job market is
very large and it's only growing so
these are the main reasons of why you
would want to learn tensorflow but at
the end of the day maybe you just want
to learn it for fun
so that depends on you
so just a quick note before we continue
with the course material we will be
using an ide and not notebooks
we will be specifically using visual
studio code
and this is for several reasons in
industry projects you usually use ides
and not notebooks
with ides you easily scale your machine
learning code so you can add a lot of
scripts you can test them separately you
can import them in different
and other scripts
and also
the i am for the opinion that says that
ides are for building your projects and
notebooks are for presenting your work
so for me and i think many other machine
learning practitioners agree with me on
this is that we usually use notebooks
for presenting the work
but when we're building large
machine learning projects we usually go
with ides
so the first thing we're going to start
doing is downloading visual studio code
is an ide that we will be using
throughout the course to write the code
and also to
run that code so if you go to
code.visualstudio.com you're going to
get this page here and as you can see it
automatically detected my system so i
can just click here and download visual
studio code for my windows machine if
you have a different machine
it should detect it if not then you can
just click on this button here and
choose the right software for your
machine so if you click this
you're just going to get this download
here and you can just save it to your
machine and run this executable just
like you would run
on
any other installation process there's
nothing unique or special here so i'm
not going to go through it here
now after we install it
if you go to
your run
menu here and you just type
visual
studio
code
you're gonna get this
uh
the icon here where you can run visual
studio code usually i like to
pin it to my start so as you can see
it's already pinned here which means i
can just access it from here you can
choose to do that as well if you prefer
that
so
let's run visual studio code
and the first time you run it you're
gonna get
this new window here where you have
the starting menu so you can
create new file
open a file or
or do all of these
other things and also for me as you can
see i have this part here that says
recent which are my recent projects
if it's the first time you're using
visual studio code you will not have
this
so
the first thing i'm gonna do is just to
open a folder so i'm gonna click on open
a folder here you can choose any place
on your machine to
to open that folder
so for me i have chosen this place on my
machine so
i have a disk called d code for courses
and introduction to tensorflow 2.
i created this new folder and now i'm
just gonna select it so select folder
and now it's gonna open this uh new
window
okay here it says uh if i trust the
authors of this files yes no problem
these are my files
so here
you get this new window where you have
this empty folder on the left
and you can add new files you can also
add new folders inside of this folder
and here we will get
uh
the place where we can write code and
also we can get the terminal at the
bottom here
so for now this is it for installing and
setting up
a visual studio code what we're going to
do
now is look at the other software that
we will use throughout the course and
also later we're going to start adding
files here so that we can start writing
some code
so the second software we need to
install
is called miniconda
so
if you look online you're gonna find
two types of products for condo there's
mini conda and there's anaconda anaconda
is actually a gui that allows you to do
almost everything that mini conda allows
you to do the only difference is that
uniconda does not have a gui
we will just use it in a
command line prompt so if you type
miniconda in your google search bar
you're gonna get
the first result here so if just open
this
here you get all of these links to
install miniconda on your machine so if
you are on windows you choose this
otherwise you choose the
other types here
and again this there's nothing special
here you can just click the link save it
save the file to your
to your local machine and then run the
installation process and also there is
nothing special
when installing minicanda so i'm not
going to go through it here
now
when you install miniconda
if you go to your
run menu here and you just type
you're going to see anaconda prompt
and between that parentheses there is
minicom.3 so if you open it you're going
to see that it looks just like the
command window
on windows
so they are
basically
or almost identical
the
only difference that we can notice here
is that
here we see this
name
called base between parentheses here and
here we can see it in the default
windows
command line window
now what this means is that in fact
in the miniconda prompt prompt
we are
actually now inside what's called a
virtual environment
and this virtual environment is called
base
so
i'll go a little bit into more details
about what these virtual environments do
and why
would we need them
and why don't we just install things
straight uh on our system using just the
windows
command line prompt
i'll go into details about this
just next
so what are these virtual environments
well you can actually think of them as
these separate entities inside your
system but they do not necessarily
affect your system
so
for example we can think of it in this
way so you have your system and inside
your system you have python say 3.8
installed and you have some python
packages
and now with virtual environments what
we can do is create
as many environments as we want so for
example here i can create i show you an
example where we created three different
virtual environments so the first one
is called vm1
the second one vm2 and we have vm3 so in
the first one
we can install python 3.7
and for example we installed tensorflow
2.6
now when you do this you're not actually
installing uh python or the python
packages straight onto your system
you're actually installing them inside
this virtual environment so this virtual
environment
it actually lives inside your system but
what you install in it does not
necessarily affect your system so here
as you can see on your system you might
have
python version 3.8
but inside your virtual environment you
can change that and you can use python
3.7
and as you can see you can create as
many virtual environments as you like
and the goal here or the why would you
even want to do something like this
is really
when you're doing machine learning or
data science you're going to be doing
lots of experimentation so for example
there might be a new tensorflow version
that has some new functionalities and
you want to test it
if you have everything installed on your
system and then you just upgrade to the
newest version of tensorflow then you
might
affect your existing code so you might
something that
has already worked in the previous
version of tensorflow may not work in
the newest version
and that could cause a lot of conflicts
so now that now you find yourself in a
situation where you have to go back to
an older version which is not uh very
good
so when you do this you can do these
experimentations separately and as you
can see
for example if i want to test pytos and
i don't want it to be used in the same
virtual environment as tensorflow i can
create
uh completely separate virtual
environments
install
uh
whatever version of python i need and
then i install pytorch here and if i
want to test for example an older
version of pytorch i can create another
virtual environment and do the same
thing
and you can imagine all of these
benefits that you can have for example
many companies are still using
tensorflow version 1.x
so
if you want to do this if you want to
install a
previous version or older version of
tensorflow so 1.5 1.6
then it's better to install it in a
virtual environment instead of doing it
on your system
so this is uh the goal of why we're
trying to use virtual environments i
really encourage you to use this kind of
framework when you're doing your
experimentation instead of installing
everything on your system
i've
been working in the machine learning
field for some years now and i have
always found that it's better to use
virtual environments rather than install
everything on your
directly on your system so i hope that
now you can see the benefits of
following this kind of paradigm
and next let's start creating a virtual
environment and installed necessary
python and python packages inside of it
so now just before we start installing
tensorflow
and
creating our virtual environment let me
just
clear some
some of the doubt that you might have
here so as you can see when we installed
miniconda we have this command prompt
here and also i showed you that we have
the default
windows command line
here and they are similar but how are we
going to use
our virtual virtual environments inside
visual studio code
so in fact if you go to visual studio
code if you go to terminal new terminal
here in fact we are inside our
command line
[Music]
default command line window
so what you do here is going to be
identical to what you would do here
and in fact let's just for example type
python so here you see on my system
there's python 3.6.8
installed
and here if i write python i get the
same uh version here so i have
whatever i do here i'll uh i'll be able
to do it here and vice versa
and
now let me just exit this
what we want is to actually be able to
use
our virtual environments and just use
mini conda in general inside our
terminal here on visual studio code so
in order to do that what you can do is
just look up where miniconda is
installed on your machine so for me i'm
using a tool called everything it's a
search tool
you don't have to install it i just
prefer it
than the
default search tool on windows
so here when i type miniconda3
which is the software that we installed
if i open this
folder here
there is another folder called scripts
and then there is activate.bat so if i
just take this copy it
paste it
and then
run activate dot that
now as you can see i have
the base name here written before
my
before this path here
and as you can see we have the same
thing here so now we are in fact inside
the virtual environment called base and
whatever you do
inside
this command
this window here is going to be
reflected here and vice versa so now
that we have
we can access
condyle commands on our
visual studio code terminal let's try to
see what we can do with it so here
let me just
clear this
part here
and in fact you can run so many conduct
commands so to run the contact command
you
start by
writing canda and then you finish the
rest of the command with whatever you
need to do so for example we can look at
our uh virtual environments that are
already installed
in order to do that you can run this
command calenda info dash dash ms and if
you've never had a mini conda before
you will have nothing
when you run this command but for me as
you can see i already have some virtual
environments installed here so let me
just
clear this one here
and next what we're going to do is
create a new virtual environment and
then
we will choose the right python version
that we want and then we're going to
install tensorflow inside that virtual
environment
to create a virtual environment using
canda the command that you should run is
kanda
create
dash and
now you can give a name to your virtual
environment you can choose any name you
like
usually for me since i do many
experimentations with tensorflow i just
like to call it for example
tf2
uh or i give it the full for example
version of tensorflow so tf 2.5 or 0.6
or whatever
and here let's just call it for example
tf2
vm
so vm for virtual environment and then
you can give it the parameter python and
here you can choose whatever version of
python you like so let's just use 3.8
since i've been working with it for uh
for a long time and it's uh it works
great with tensorflow
so here i'm just gonna run this command
so now it's gonna ask us whether we
accept to install these unnecessary
packages so i'm gonna choose yes and
click
and this should not take that long
because these are not large packages so
after we have our packages installed we
can run
kanda
activate tf2
vm
and
of course you can see that the
suggestion is shown here in order to
activate your virtual environment so
now if you remember we are inside a
virtual environment called base so after
i run this command now we're inside our
new newly created virtual environment
called tf2 vm and here whatever you
install
is going to be
separate from your system so it will not
affect it so here for example let's just
run python and as you can see is version
3.8 if you remember on my system i have
3.6
installed but here inside my virtual
environment because i specified that i
want
python version 3.8 i have 3.8 installed
here
so now that we are we have created our
virtual environment we start installing
the necessary packages so
now we can install for example
tensorflow and if you go to the official
website of tensorflow
you can see if you just go to
tensorflow.org install you can see
different ways you can install uh
tensorflow for us we're gonna use
uh tensorflow or download it and install
it as a python package so these are the
commands we can run
so here uh
first command we can run as just for
upgrading pip so if you don't know what
bib is so bip is just a package manager
that helps us install python packages so
let me paste it here
and see if i don't have the latest
version apparently
not so it's just gonna download it and
install it
so when i tried to upgrade pip on my
machine it gave me a
basically an access error but uh
you if you have that error you can just
run the same command but you add dash
dash user at the end
so for me it says requirements already
satisfied in fact i didn't really need
to run this command i already had the
last
version of pip already installed but you
can run it just
for
the sake of it
and now we're gonna
use this command so pip install
tensorflow and here i just want to
mention something really quickly as you
can see it mentions that the current
stable release for cpu and gpu so when
you run this command it's gonna install
the
stable versions for both cpu and gpu
support
before
i can't remember before which
release from tensorflow but before
in order to install the gpu version you
would add tensorflow
gpu so you specifically mentioned that
you want to install tensorflow with gpu
support but apparently now when you when
you just run this command it's gonna
install
the
stability release for cpu and gpu
so
i'm gonna go back to
my virtual environment here i'm just
gonna paste it pip install tensorflow
and let's run this command
[Music]
again just
to
mention this important point whatever
we're installing here is being installed
inside our virtual environment and not
inside our system
so this might take a little time
depending on your internet speed and on
your system so when the download and
installation is finished
i'll be back to show you what we can do
next
so now i have
tensorflow downloaded and installed
inside my virtual environment
and i can verify that for example by
running python console here and just
trying to import
tensorflow
and it should be imported without any
problems and just
to show you that we're actually not
installing things inside our
uh on our system directly here if i run
python and i do
import
tensorflow you see that module name
or module not found here so it doesn't
find the tensorflow module because it's
not installed on my system
i'm just showing you this here because
from time to time you might face a
problem like this and you start asking
yourself why
why don't i have tensorflow when you
have already installed it but just make
sure that if you install it in one
specific virtual environment you should
be using that virtual environment to run
your code and
this just this small detail here could
help you solve this kind of errors
and now that we have it what i would
like to do is just run a command
tensorflow.config.list
physical
[Music]
devices
so what this command is going to do is
to show me on my
machine which
devices can i use to train deep learning
models using tensorflow
so as you can see here i have
two devices there is the cpu and there
is the gpu there's only one gpu as you
can see
for you
it's very likely if it's the first time
you're using tensorflow it's very likely
that you will not have this second part
here you won't have the gpu
and
this could be for several reasons for
example you may not have an nvidia gpu
on your machine so that's
a common reason why you wouldn't have
this
the second common reason is that you
might have an nvidia gpu but
it's not
it doesn't have support for training
tensorflow or deep learning models in
general on that gpu
and the
if you
if you're not in one of these two
categories then most likely
you're not seeing the gpu because you
just haven't
set up what's necessary in order for you
to run the training on
the gpu and for me i have already done
the necessary setup
and i do have a
nvidia gpu that can run the training
that's why i'm seeing it here
for you if you
don't
fall in the first two categories and you
know that you can run the training on
your gpu then i'll show you next what
are the necessary uh hardware
requirements and software requirements
what are the things that you need to
install in order to be able to use your
gpu
if you want to be able to run the
training on your gpu and you know that
you have nvidia gpu
one thing you can do is to follow the
right process that's mentioned in the
official tensorflow installation
page
so
here if you go to the download package
which is what we just used
if you go to gpu guide
you can open this page here and
when we when you use a bib package like
we're doing you need to have some
hardware requirements and also software
requirements so the first thing let's
check the hardware requirements so as
you can see here it mentions that
there are some nvidia cards where you
can
that are supported
for
you to train deep learning models on
them so if you open
this list here of cards that are that
have cuda enabled architectures you can
see a list of devices here and you can
try to find whether your device is
inside this list or not
so in fact funnily enough
for me i actually have a card geforce
gtx 1050 ti
and
it doesn't exist on this list but i
still can run the training on it anyway
i remember the first time when i checked
the list i didn't find it then i just
started searching online i found that
many people said yes they have the same
card and they were able to run the
training on it so this is just
a small remark
but uh if you find your card here then
that's you can definitely run the
training on the gpu
so that's the first thing you need to
check
uh
if you have that
then most likely you can run the
training and then you have some
some remarks mentioned here for example
for gpus with unsupported cuda
architectures
or to avoid compilation use different
versions of nvidia so you can check
these if you
uh if you fall into one of these
categories but for me usually just
checking whether the architecture works
is enough
and then for the software requirements
this is where
in fact you need to have some software
installed before
your
nvidia card can recognize
that you can do the training using
tensorflow
so the first thing is
the nvidia
gpu drivers
so here it says cuda 11.2 requires 450
or higher
so you can go to
the website here and for me it has
automatically detected in fact i think
that it's because i have already done
this so maybe it's saved in my
in the cookies but uh
for you if it doesn't if you don't see
your machine directly here you can just
go search for it manually so you choose
the product type the product series and
then at the end
you just click search and it's gonna
give you the download link
and again this is
when you download this and you start uh
installing it
okay it does didn't start automatically
let me click again okay now when you
have this on your machine you just run
the installation process there's nothing
really special you just go next next
next and you install everything so
that's the first thing that you need to
do
and then
you have
cuda toolkits
that you need to install
and just i want to mention something
here because uh i think a lot of people
make a mistake when they start
installing
all of this software
so here specifically it mentions for
example cuda 11.2
and also tensorflow supports cuda 11.2
so any version of tensorflow that's
higher than 2.5
it requires
cuda 11.2
so for us we have installed
tensorflow so if i do
for example
tensorflow and then i just
run
or check the version of tensorflow
insert flow
version
so here you can see i have version 2.6.0
so i do fall into this category i need
to have cuda 11.2
uh installed
here when you go to the cuda toolkit
archive you
just don't take the latest version for
example i see many people do this
mistake they just go to the latest
version but here if it's mentioned that
you need to use 11.2 then you need to
look for 11.2
and here what i usually do is i take the
latest version
of 11.2 because here you can see there's
11.2.0.1.2
so i just take this one here
and then you just choose your operating
system the architecture is only one here
version 10 of windows and then you can
choose one of two options
[Music]
there is the local installer and the
network installer the difference is that
the local installer has a large file
which doesn't require a require internet
access i mean after you download it you
don't require uh internet access in
order to install
cuda toolkit
and this one
is a smaller file but it does require
internet access if you have good
internet then i suggest you just
download this small file
if not then you can download the largest
file here and again
there is nothing really special about
this you just download it and then you
go next next next there is
and then you have the cuda toolkit
installed on your machine so that's the
second part
uh for the cup tie you don't need to do
that it mentions here that it ships with
cuda toolkit so
if you have the kuda toolkit you already
have kubtai
and then you need to install crew dnn
sdk
8.1.0
so if we click this
let me check here
so download cooldmn
and in fact
for you to download that
file or that folder
you need to be a member
on the website and this is you can do
this for free you can just
log in if you already have an account or
you can join now
for example and you just uh use your
email and
there is nothing special here you just
join the
the
website
so for me i already have a an account
here
so once i log
into my account
i get this web page here so i'm just
going to agree to the terms and then
here you can download the version
for
uh or kudianon 8.2.4
and in fact here when you look at this
you see that there is for cuda 11.4 and
this is for cuda 11.2 let's see if we
can find for cuda
11.2
so there is none
in that case
we're just gonna use the latest version
here so let me just go back here and
check
okay we have the cuda versions
yes apparently
okay 11.1 here
yeah in fact there is so
this is again this is a sometimes a
problem that many people face so here we
need hoo dnn sdk 8.1.0
when i clicked on the qdnn versions i
get to this website here and here if you
just don't take the latest version you
need to look for your own specific
version
so here i have
uh
the
version
8.1.0 which is
what we need so for eight point one
point zero we have one for cuda 10.2 and
then one for cuda point eleven point
zero point one and point two
for us we have cuda
11.2
as you remember so
we need
this
this version here
so these are small details but just
make sure you follow them so that you
don't face a problem later
many times i find people saying that
they installed everything but still
their car does not recognize uh
cannot do the training with tensorflow
but usually the problem just comes from
one of these small details
so if you click this
then you can choose the right software
for your machine so for example we are
on a windows machine so i can just click
goody and then library for windows
and this is going to download
a zipped folder
and in fact i already have it on my
machine here
now i'm going to show you what
what you need to do with this folder
so when you installed
cuda 11.2
it was installed in this path here so if
you go to c program files nvidia gpu
computing toolkit
then you go to cuda
for me i have several versions of cruda
because
from time to time i would
upgrade or use the newest version of
tensorflow and then many times it
requires new version of cuda so i would
download
and install the right cuda version for
you if you've never did this before then
probably you will have only one
version which is 11.2
and now
what we're gonna do with the
uh the zipped folder that you downloaded
what you need to do is to unzip it so
when you unzip it you're gonna get
a folder called cuda inside of it you're
gonna have these folders and this file
here
so what we're gonna do now is basically
just copy the contents from these
folders to the corresponding folders
in cuda 11.2 so for example you would go
to the bin folder
copy everything then go
here and paste everything
for me i've already copied and pasted
these so i'm not going to do it but this
is the only thing you need to do then
you go to the include
folder
copy everything paste it in the
include folder
and last
you go to the
lib folder you copy everything inside
x64
and then the same thing here lib you go
to
x64 and then you paste everything there
when you do this you can go back to
your terminal
so what i would suggest is to
close
and reopen the terminal
and then
if you run the same command that we that
i showed you before so
for example let's just do it again
import
tensorflow
so here if we
if we run
tensorflow.list or
config
not list
physical
devices
now you should be able to see this
gpu part here so
now i have shown you exactly the full
process of installing a tensorflow so
that you can use it with your gpu if you
have a cuda enabled nvidia gpu
and this is gonna allow you to run the
train the training of your deep learning
models much much faster
which is uh almost always recommended
and with this
let's now look at what we can start
adding
from the coding part so that we can
start exploring tensorflow
library
so here we're gonna start with the
first
classification task using tensorflow and
it's actually a classical task so
basically what we want to achieve
is
uh to build a system that can take
images like this one here or here or
here and at the output it would tell us
whether there is a three or there's a
seven there's a zero inside that image
so our data set looks something like
this of course these think of these are
as separate
small
images just like these ones here these
are just put together here for
visualizations
purposes
so our data set has so many zeros so
many ones twos until the digit nine
and we want to build a system that can
take an image like this
at the at the start or as an input and
adds the at the output we want to get
the value that's written inside of that
uh
of that image
so it's always good to really think
about
whatever task you're trying to achieve
before you start the coding part so here
this is just a quick overview of what we
want to achieve and in fact this amnest
test is
a
uh you can say as a tradition in the
deep learning community it's just like a
hello world
program when you're learning a new
programming language so now
that you have
hopefully understood the purpose of this
task let's get into the code and see
what
how we can achieve this
this goal here
now let's get to the coding part so the
first thing i'm going to do is just add
a new file
i'm going to call for example mnist
example.buy
and it's automatically opened on this
side here
so let's start by importing
for example
tensorflow since we will definitely need
it later
and
one thing we gonna add from the start is
just
check if
name
equals
main
[Music]
then we're going to run the code so
if you're not familiar with this
python
part here just means that
if i run my
script then i want this part here to be
rand and if i import it for example i
can import my file into another script
and in that case this part will not be
called it's a good habit to
always add this one
[Music]
on your scripts when you want
to separate the behaviors between
importing those scripts and running
those scripts
so the first thing that you might notice
here is that it says
tensorflow is not accessed it doesn't
find tensorflow
so here in fact what's happening is that
if
if you run your script from the terminal
then there will be no problem
so if i do python
and this example dot y
nothing is going to happen but
there will be no problem that's what i
mean
but here if you try to run it using the
run button here
then you see it says no module named
tensorflow and in fact what just
happened is that
vs code has opened a new terminal window
automatically and it tried to run this
script
using our
python that exists on our system and not
inside our virtual environment
so in fact we still have our virtual
environment here and this is the new
terminal window that was
started by vs code
so
in order to run your scripts so you can
in fact just ignore these
these warnings here and you just run
your script from the terminal but if
this
uh is annoying for you as it is for me
you can fix it by
actually telling vs code that this code
here that we're writing is going to be
around inside our virtual environment
tf2vm so in order to do that you can
click ctrl shift p
on your keyboard so again ctrl shift p
you push them
you click them together and then you
just search for
interpreter and you choose python select
interpreter
and here is going to give you a list of
a different python
executables that it found on your system
and here we're going to look for the
virtual environment that we created so
it's called tf2bn
so
let's just go
step by step here try to find it so i
have many virtual environments that's
why it's not clear okay it's this one
for you you may not have all of these
virtual environments so it will be
quick to spot which one is the
environment that you created
so i'm gonna click on tf2 vm and now as
you can see
vs code recognizes tensorflow because
it's installed inside our virtual
environment
and i can click this one here
and
as you can see the program runs
correctly with no problem
so
now let's go to our code editor here and
let's start
looking into what we can do
for our task that we defined previously
so
one thing we can start doing is by
actually importing the data set
so in fact
if you're doing a new project with your
own data set it may not be
this easy but since this is the first
example of the first tutorial we're
gonna do we're just gonna use the
easiest and the quickest things so that
we can put something together and see uh
see basically the workflow of a
tensorflow
program
so what we're gonna do is use
tensorflow.js
dot
data sets
or
let me just check
yes in fact it should be data sets
dot
load
or dot mnist
dot
load
data
so
let me just do this and in fact what
this is going to do is load our data but
we need to tell it
where to store it so for us
we're just going to use
x train
for the training data set and y train
for the corresponding labels
and then
we're gonna use
x test
and y
test
so what this is going to do is
load the mnist data set in fact if it's
not if it doesn't exist on your system
if it's the first time you'll be running
this
program here then it will download it
first
and then it's gonna load it into these
variables that we defined here
and it's already split into two parts
one for training and one for testing
so
let's run this command or this program
here and just
i would like to
print the shapes of
these uh these variables that we defined
and that we're going to load our data
set in them so xtrain
dot shape
and let me just run this
and i'm just gonna
paste this
three times and i want to do this for
every variable that we have here
ctrl c
ctrl v
so
now let me just run my
script again from the terminal
and let's see what we get
so as you can see it has loaded the data
set
and
it has put them into these variables and
we can see the shapes
or basically the size of the data set so
as you can see for the training part
there are 60 000 images each image is of
28 by 28 pixels
the labels there are sixty thousand
labels because each image has its own
label
and by the label here i mean that if an
image contains the number three in it
then the label will be the number three
and for the test part we have 10 000
images and of course their corresponding
10 000
labels
so just just a quickly to go through why
do we separate our data set into these
two parts so in fact in deep learning
what we do is
we do some sort of cross validation
there are many types of cross validation
the simplest one is to
split the data set into two parts one
you're gonna use to train your model and
one you're gonna use to validate your
model
and the difference is that during the
training
these are the examples that will be used
and at the end of each epoch
uh what's going to happen is that the
neural network is going to run
one forward pass of these test examples
and this is going to give you an idea of
how your neural network is performing on
data that's not used during the training
so it's this is going to give you an
idea of uh how well the network is
learning
so this is just you can keep it in mind
there's a whole theory behind this but i
just want to go quickly
through this so that you understand why
do we have these two different splits
so
now what is usually good to do is to
explore more your data set so what we
have done here is some sort of an
exploration we
basically checked the size of our data
set we now know that each image is 28 by
28 pixels but it's also good to
plot some of the examples and their
corresponding labels
so for that i'm just going to create a
help helping function so i'm going to
call it for example
display some
examples
and what's going to take
as parameters are the
examples or data points and the labels
so basically what i want to do here is
create a figure and add
many of the images randomly i'll choose
them randomly from the data set and then
i'll add them inside uh
this figure and then i'm gonna plot this
figure so that we can see those images
so one thing you can use
which is a very famous package in python
is a matplotlib so
usually we just call it plt for short
and in order to do that you need to
import
matte blot lib dot
pi
as plt
and then you can use this package
to do all sorts of things like creating
figures and adding
different images
on those figures
so as you can see here
visual studio code does not recognize
this package here because in fact we
don't have it installed inside our
virtual machine
so before we go
anywhere let's
just
installed it and to install any new
package you can just run pip
install and the name of the package so
matt lard lib
and usually
i
install packages on the go so whenever i
need the package i installed it i
don't like to install many things in the
beginning
because i don't know beforehand which
ones which of the packages i'll
definitely need and which ones i won't
need so usually i just write my code and
whenever i need a package i install it
on the spot so here let me run pip
install map.lib
so it shouldn't take long
okay it's installed and now it should be
recognized i guess
maybe it's not
refreshed automatically but now we can
use plt
so
we're going to start by creating a
figure
and we're going to give it a fix size of
let's say 10
by 10
[Music]
and
then what we're gonna do is
basically
plot 25 images so it's going to be a
grid of five by five
so we're gonna do a for loop so for i
in range
25 so i'm choosing 25 here you can
choose whatever number you like for me i
think 25 images is already enough to get
an idea about your data set
and here the first thing i'm gonna do is
randomly choose so each time i'm going
to randomly choose an index
from
my
data set so let me just code it and it's
going to be
much clearer so i'm going to do index
and
numpy
okay i don't have numpy
imported so let me just
import
numpy snp and here i'm just gonna do np
dot
random
dot rant in so i want to
randomly choose an integer
and i really like this uh kind of a
tooltip that comes
when you're coding on visual studio code
and it basically gives you a small
documentation about that function and
what you can do with it
so here for this function we need to
give it a lower
end and the higher end and it's going to
use an integer between those two numbers
so here i'm going to choose something
between 0 and the size of
so examples
dot shape
and
i'm going to do 0
and here minus 1. so
what am i doing here so if you remember
here
whether you choose the training set or
the test set for example the training
set there is 60 000 images so i want to
choose a number between 0
and
basically
59 999
because that would represent the number
corresponding to the last image
and here this is all i'm doing so here
i'm basically choosing between zero and
uh
and sixty thousand minus one
and then what i'm gonna do is use this
index
to
get the corresponding image so now i can
do examples
index
and then i want to get also the
corresponding label
so i'm gonna do labels
and index
and now i'm gonna
plot that specific image so for that i'm
gonna use plt
subplot
[Music]
and just make sure i think there are
there is subplot and subplots but what
you want to use a subplot without the s
and here we gonna give it basically the
grid
size so it's a 5x5 because we want to
plot
25 images
and
here
this is the number of
the image
and here i'm gonna do
plot
i'm gonna first
plot the
sorry here the title
so the title of each image i want it to
be the corresponding label so
and it also needs to be into a string
sorry so here i'm just gonna transform
my
label
into a string so this is going to be the
title of each
uh image and then
i'm going to add
an mshow
method to show the corresponding image
so here i'm going to do
show my image
and at the end you need to tell
python that
show
all of the figure now
so now that we have this function coded
let's try it out here
by calling the name of the function then
let's run it on the train set so here
i'm gonna run it on the xtrain and y
train
so let me clear the terminal quickly
and
do
python
mnistexample.buy
so now as you can see we get
these images in a 5x5 grid
and
we have all of these examples now one
thing you
you might
observe is that we have these images
that have this kind of weird color
and also we have
basically the space between the images
is too small so we don't clearly see
that okay this is this has a label of
nine but it's not very clear so let's
fix these two problems quickly now
so first of all we know that our images
are grayscale images they're not rgb
images
because here we see that the size is 28
by 28 which means there's only one
channel and there are no there are three
channels so it's not an rgb image
so in order to tell matplotlib that this
is a grayscale image we can use
the c-map
argument here and we can tell it that
it's actually gray
and to fix the problem of the layouts
what we can do is
use plt
dot type layout
and this is gonna automatically
add more space so that we can
see the labels and the images uh in a
much more understandable way so let me
run the command again
python
and this example.buy
and as you can see now it looks much
more clear
these are
the images that exist inside our data
set they are grayscale images and
above each one we have the corresponding
label so this is a two this is a one a
one this is a four a three here a six so
we have all of these examples and why do
we do this it's just a way to basically
quickly check your data set sometimes
what happens is that when you're
building your own data set and you do
this kind of exploration you quickly
spot some things for example you might
spot that this is a zero but uh
but it's not labeled correctly
for example you must see that this is
labeled as nine when it's actually a
zero
so that's gonna give you
basically just quick hint that there is
there are problems
with your data set
and you can maybe go fix them quickly
and the good thing is that whenever you
run this script it's going to choose
randomly different images so you can see
different parts of your data set each
time you run the script so here we have
the two six one for example in the
beginning just so that we can remember
and let's run it again
okay
and now as you can see we have five 572
instead of the
261 i think it was before
so
this is just about the exploration of
your data set as i mentioned it's always
a good idea to do these quick
exploration steps before we start doing
anything
and now that we see that okay our data
set is
more or less okay
let's see what we can do next
in regards of creating a model and later
training it
now that we have our data set
loaded and ready
let's see how we can build our neural
network
so in fact tensorflow
gives you access to so many layers
that you can use to build your neural
network so if for example you
do from
tensorflow
import here you have
many different layers that you can
import
for our classification task and for many
of the computer vision tasks
we usually have a set of layers that we
basically always use so
these layers are
conf
2d
so this is a 2d convolution
we also
uh always
use
of course an input layer so here i'm
going to add input so this is a layer
that basically gets our input and then
passes it to the rest of the layers
and
there is also the dense layer
so it's also called fully connected
layer
we have the
max pool 2d
so since we're doing 2d convolutions
we're going to combine them with a max
pool 2d
and
it's always good to use batch
normalization to normalize our batches
and also
we might
want to use a flattened layer
which basically takes the output from
some
multi-dimensional layers like a
convolutional layer and then it just
flattens them and puts them in
some sort of a vector
and also in fact
in many cases
you can use just
global
average pooling
or global
sorry here global
average pool 2d
so this layer also can uh
can work in a way that's
closely similar with flattened but
they're different in the way they do it
so flatten basically takes all of the
uh all of the
outputs of a previous layer puts them
into a vector but
in the global average pooling there is
some sort of a
compute computation of the mean
based on some axis and then
the output
usually is much smaller than the output
given by a flattened layer so
here
i'm basically mentioning some of the
basic layers that we use in a neural
network for doing
image processing or doing uh
deep learning for images type of things
so for classification this is one case
there's also object detection image
segmentation
all of these
tasks usually you're going to find this
type of layers in them and sometimes you
find more complex layers
and sometimes those complex layers are
just
basically stacking together different uh
basic layers like these ones here
so
these are the layers that we're gonna
use to build our neural network
and now let's see how we can build that
neural network there are several
ways and mainly three ways that you can
build a neural network in tensorflow
we're gonna explore them now one by one
the three approaches that tensorflow
gives us or provides us in order to be
able to build deep learning models are
the following
so
the first approach is by using
tensorflow.keras dot sequential
so you can call it the sequential way
this is the easiest way to build a deep
learning model you just stack different
layers together
and we're gonna do this in a minute
the second approach is by
what's called
the functional way
or the functional approach so basically
here you build a
function
that
returns
a
deep learning model or just let's just
write a model
and the third approach
is to basically inherit from a base
class
this base class is in
tensorflow.keras
dot
model so you inherit from this class and
then
you
you re-implement or you overwrite some
of the methods of this class
and then you can have a deep learning
model so
inherit
from this class
so these are the three different
approaches let's start with the first
one
so in order to build a deep learning
model
architecture using this sequential class
in fact it's very easy you just call for
example
let's
call our model model and then
you
call this
sequential
class
and show
and
then you can start
stacking layers here
so
what we start with always is an input
layer so here
we're going to use the
input layer that we imported here
and what this input layer takes
as a an argument it takes many arguments
but the main one that we need to set is
the shape of the input
so as you remember our images are 28 by
28
and
they only have uh one channel they are
grayscale images so there's only one
channel this means that our input needs
to be 28 by 28 by one
one represents only one channel
and then the second layer that we're
gonna add here is going to take as input
this layer
and usually when you're doing image
classification
[Music]
tasks or other computer vision related
tasks in deep learning you take the
image and then you pass it through some
convolutional layers so here we're going
to do the same thing so conf 2d
and
since this is the
the first
convolutional layer
let's go through some of the
parameters that exist
in this layer so one thing that i like
to do is
to just hold the ctrl key and then hover
over that class and as you can see
visual studio code can give you so many
information about that class
and here the mandatory
parameters that we need to set are
filters and the kernel size and then you
have the rest of the parameters already
set you can change them if you like
and here even gives you some examples
and they give some explanations of the
different
different parameters
so
the number of filters here so let's
start with for example
32 filters of size 3
by 3
and here let's also set an activation
function
and i'm going to use
a real u activation function
so here there are all of these
parameters what do they
basically represent for us so this
number here the 32 represents how many
filters or how many uh
basically
well each filter
has a set of weights and in fact here
we're defining how many
weights values are in that filter
so
this means that we're creating 32
filters each filter filter is three by
three of size
and then we're choosing an activation
function here
we're choosing rectified linear unit
there are several activation functions
and all of these parameters you might be
thinking why do we choose 32 and not
another one why do we
choose three by three and this is real
you why do we choose these specific
parameters where in fact
these parameters are hyperparameters you
might have heard of this term and these
are parameters that you can
change and each time you change and you
train your new deep learning model and
you see whether the
accuracy has improved or not so far
there's no
very solid theory on
how many parameters you should choose in
each phase so it's really an
experimental
approach you choose some of these
parameters you train your model and then
you go change them again and train your
model again and see if you get a better
accuracy
now i am choosing some of these
parameters based on
much previous work that has been done by
researchers if you see a lot of the
neural networks used for classification
they would start with something very
similar to this so i am following on
their footsteps because i know that they
have done so many experimentations
with those neural networks
so here i'm going to start with a
convolutional layer
usually what we do is we create a block
of convolution where you have a
convolutional layer then you would use
max pool
2d
and
then you would use a batch normalization
layer
and then you can do the same thing again
another convolution max pool
normalization and you just change for
example the number of filters or the
filter size here or the activation
function
so what this max pool 2d does is that it
takes the output of the convolution and
it looks in both directions and based on
the pool size so again let's maybe go to
the documentation
that's
written inside the code here
what you have is
let me just go way down you have the
pool size
and it's two by two what this means
is that the output of the convolution
we're gonna look a two by two window of
the output of this layer
and each time we're gonna use we're
gonna keep only the max value between
those four values because it's a two by
two window so there are four values we
only keep the
max value
between all of those four values and
here you can in fact change this you can
set the pull size to four by four which
means it's a four by four window where
you keep only the max value in that
in that window
and again why do we keep two by two why
don't we change it as
these are also hyper parameters that you
can change and each time you change you
retrain your model and see whether you
get better results so this also goes
into that experimental
experimentation approach
that we do at uh as machine learning
engineers or data scientists
so
this is one way to do things and the
in fact you're not
you're not let's say
you don't strictly need to follow these
approaches
you can experiment for example you can
add
a convolution to the here
and you
for example let's do 64
and the three by three
and activation
is uh
is it activations or activation sorry
let me just
check again
[Music]
so here
let me go into the parameters
activation now it's only is without an s
okay
so you can do this you can remove it you
can add another layer
feel free to experiment with this uh
architecture because this is where
deep learning is is different than uh
conventional software engineering you
can do so much experimentation with all
of these things and you will have
different results and only based on
those results you can say that your
model is better than the previous ones
or not
so here let's for example keep it like
this and let's create another stack of
layers here
so conf
2d
and i'm gonna for example use 128
filters
keep them three by three
and
the activation
is the same
as before so real you
and
this approach here where i take 32 64
and 128 is also something that i've seen
being done in research so many neural
network architectures follow this kind
of
approach where each time they double the
number of filters so i'm choosing to do
that but in fact nothing is stopping you
from using
other numbers here you can use for
example 110
or just 100 or whatever you like so i'm
gonna
finish the architecture using the same
approach here
so now i have
these layers that are
very similar so we take an input we do
some convolution here then the second
convolution we max pool we do batch
normalization then again we do
convolution max polling batch
normalization and here just if i didn't
mention batch normalization before so
batch normalization is basically looks
at your batches and does normalization
on that batch this is an operation that
is that is inspired from the
uh normalization of the input which is
something that we're going to do a
little later
so
basically researchers have noticed that
when you normalize your input this helps
the gradient
the computational of the gradient and it
helps when we're trying to minimize our
cost function so some other researchers
said okay if we're normalizing our
inputs why not normalize the
outputs of the layers inside the neural
network so this is why
they created this
new type of layer where it takes the
output of this previous layer and then
it normalized the the batches so each
time we have a new batch we normalize
the data inside that batch
and finally since we finished the
convolutional parts here which are
the
main
layers that's going to affect our neural
network because they can learn so much
and you can
check some of the
papers about this
maybe the young lacoon
paper which was the first one that
introduced the
convolution or 2d convolution and you
can see how much we're saving in memory
and how much they actually improved the
results
now let's get to the
part where we basically built what comes
later at our
neural network architecture
so here i'm going to use a global
average pooling
and then i'm gonna add a dense layer
i'm gonna add a dense layer of 64
units
and an activation
of
real you so i'm gonna keep the same
activation function as before
and then i'm gonna add
a final layer here
and now i'm gonna use
an activation
called soft max
and with this i have actually finished
building my neural network using the
sequential approach
and let me just go through these layers
quickly and what we're doing here so the
global average pool 2d
it takes the output from this patch
normalization layer and it computes the
average
of those values according to some axes
and then we're going to get a
set of values here and then those values
are going to be fed to a dense layer
this dense layer you can think of it as
a vector containing values so there are
no filters like the convolution
like 2d convolution here
and finally
we're going to add another
dense layer which has 10 values and this
will be the output layer of our neural
network
and
we're choosing 10 here because
in our data set the amnes data set there
are 10 different
classes that we can have from zero to
nine so there are ten classes so
again if we go back to the first uh
the first time i spoke about our
classification system i mentioned that
we want to build the system that takes
the image as an input
and we want it to tell us at the output
which of the ten categories so is it
zero one or until nine
so
this model here reflects exactly that
we're taking an input image and the
output is
a set of 10 values which will be in fact
10 probabilities we're getting
probabilities because we're using this
activation function called soft max so
the soft max gives us 10 probabilities
and they sum up to one
so what we're going to do is look at
those probabilities and look at the
highest one and that would correspond to
the class predicted by our model
so this
basically explains why we're using 10
here and we're using
the softmax activation function here and
at this stage here you don't have uh
as many options as you would have in
these layers for example in this dense
layer
you can choose
a different value here so
128 132 it doesn't matter you can change
the activation to something else
but at this level here here we are at
the output of our layer and we know that
we want to predict one of 10 values so
it has to be 10 here and also we want
those values to be probabilities so that
they reflect what the model thinks about
our image that's why we're using soft
max here
apart from this
there's also the input layer where you
don't have much
choice you have to set the
shape
that corresponds to the shape of your
dataset so we know that our images have
28 by 28 pixels so
it has to be 28 by 28
input we also know that our images are
grayscale so they have only one channel
that's why we have to choose one here so
apart from the inputs and the output
layers
these layers here you can change so many
parameters in them and each time you
train your model and see whether
it gives better results or not
so with this we're actually done
building our first neural network using
the sequential approach
now what we're going to do is continue
creating the rest of our program so that
we can make use of this model train it
and then test it on some of the examples
in our data set
so now that our model architecture is
ready
let's look at how we basically set up
the rest of the things so that we can
run the training so the first thing i
want to do here is just
basically omit this part here and one
thing that i like to do is just use some
kind of switchers here so it falls so
that
i don't like to comment the code that's
uh that's important and also i don't
like to delete it so i just like to use
this kind of approach here
and now what we're going to do is
the first thing we need to consider is
that our data is in some sort of a
a row uh manner this is how we got it
from the load data method here
but before we
start to pass it through our model so
that it can start to learn
[Music]
we need to normalize it so in order to
normalize the data
we're gonna use some
basically
division approach so here we're going to
do x strain
and usually what you would do is just
divide it by
255 because our values are between 0 and
255
to 255 represents white and 0 represents
black
and the thing is our
data set here is an unsigned integer
8-bit
data type
before we do that before we do the
division i mean we need to
basically transform it into another type
so as type
and here i'm gonna do float 32 bits and
why are we doing this
is because if we don't transform it into
this
float 32-bit type
what's going to happen is that the
values that are between 0 and 255 so
let's say
2
200 for example when you divide it it's
gonna become zero instead of zero point
something that's because the data is an
unsigned integer
8 bits format but when we turn it into
32
float
format what's going to happen is that
we're going to get that zero point uh
something
which will not be absolute zero which is
which is exactly what we want to have
here
and we're gonna do the same thing for
the
test
set so
test
as
type
i'm gonna do float 32
and then divide it by 255.
so
again why do we do this normalization
approach here
uh it just it's been uh by
experimentation
we've seen that when you normalize your
data the gradient moves
faster towards
the global minimum of your cost function
but
i have to say that i have done so many
experimentations where i didn't
normalize the data and it still worked
okay there wasn't that much difference
between when i normalized and when i
didn't normalize the data but here just
for the sake of good practices i'm gonna
keep the normalization here
and
uh one thing also that we need to do is
to
basically make our data set in a in in
such a way that
our model can accept it in its input so
as you can see the input model expects
expects 28 by 28 by one
and here as you can see our data set
uh of course there are these sixty
thousand images this does not matter for
our model it's gonna take them
batch by batch but
here we see that our
arrays are formatted in such a way where
we only have two dimensions so 28 by 28
but we want to have 28 by 28 by one
so in order to remedy this we're gonna
do
x train
equals mp dot expand dims so this is to
expand the dimensions of an array and
we're going to give it
the same array so x strain and then
we can use the
axis number so here
we want to expand the last dimension so
we know that our array has
here three dimensions so
of course when they are three that means
this is dimension zero this is one this
is two so we can use for example
three here
and that would work
but
uh you can also do just minus one which
means we want to add dimension at the
end
so here we're going to do
x test the same way
so let me just copy this
and
here
i'm gonna do test
so now in fact
our data let me just maybe copy this and
paste it again just so that you can see
the difference
so now our data is normalized because we
use this
uh
these operations here and but also the
dimensions have been changed so let me
just
clear this then run
mnist example
just quickly to see what we have
differently so as you can see
we had this
shape for our data set before now we
have this
and this is
the right shape to use with our
architecture because again our
architecture accepts 28 by 28 by one of
course the first dimension that
represents the batches it doesn't matter
so we don't mention it here so uh it's
not gonna cause any problems but if we
don't have our data set in this format
it's gonna actually pose a problem and
maybe you will have this question of why
don't we just remove this here
why don't we just do this and then we
don't need to
expand the dimensions in fact if you do
this what's going to happen is that the
combo you're going to have a problem
with this layer here because the 2d
convolution expects a
4d four-dimensional tensor
and what this means is that
here we have
the this tensor that represents the
shape of the data but there will also be
a dimension here it's hidden here it's
not shown which represents the batches
so we can take several images at the
same time
so with
adding that dimension for the batches
we're going to have four
dimensions here and then the convolution
2d will not complain about dimensions so
that's why we're doing this here and
that's why we're
expanding the dimensions here
and
okay let me just maybe remove this
for now we don't need it
and now that we have
all of these
uh all of our data ready to be uh passed
through our model
let's
compile our model here
and by compiling i means i mean we're
gonna set some of the important aspects
of the training so we're going to do
model that
compile
and then inside this
function here you have several
parameters that you need to set so
there's the optimizer
and there is also the loss
and finally
there are the
metrics
so these are the three important
parameters that you need to set
so here the optimizer
what it represents is the algorithm that
we're gonna use
in order to
uh to optimize our cost function
and by optimizing i mean trying to find
the global minimum of our cost function
so for this we have several options in
tensorflow
the most famous one is
adam which we will be using but there
are or several uh
optimizers in tensorflow so let me just
maybe try to
okay sometimes it's not giving me option
to see uh
to see all of the parameters but
here we can set the parameter atom
there's also ada and there are several
others that you can use
so here if you go to the tensorflow
documentation and the
tf.keras.optimizers you see that you
have all of these options that you can
choose from there's the ada delta other
grad adam so on so forth you have the
stochastic gradient descent here
so you have all these options that you
can use again which one to use really
depends on uh the case that you are uh
you are doing and this also goes into
the hyper parameters
part where you for example you might
choose adam train your model and then
you might change that and choose for
example an adam and you might get better
results using this uh
other optimizer so it's really an
experimental approach and i again i do
encourage you to change things and see
what you can get with those different
parameters
so let me uh go back to our example here
so here
when you want to pass
a parameter to this
argument here optimizer you can just put
it between parentheses or between
these quotation marks here and you just
write the name
and you can of course
choose any of the other ones and write
it here
and this is how you set the optimizer
the second thing which is very important
that we need to set is the loss function
so
for the loss
for every task in uh in deep learning
you have a set of loss functions that
you can use for that specific
task so in classification
one of the widely used
loss functions is
called cross
entropy so these are
two different uh
two different words cross entropy
and this is actually a function that
uses uh
probabilities and
it computes some sort of probabilities
that
helps penalize your
neural network weights when they are
when the when it predicts the wrong
thing and also helps it know which
values are predicted correctly so there
is a whole
a lot of research about cross entropy
that you can look up online
but
in fact just in tensorflow you have
three different
loss functions that have the name cross
entropy in them
so here again i'm looking at the
documentation on in tensorflow and
if i didn't mention it before i would
very much
recommend looking at this documentation
from time to time it's uh written
in a quite understandable manner and you
can get a lot of information from it
so again for cross entropy if you go to
the
documentation you'll see that you have
binary cross entropy you have
categorical cross entropy and also
you have sparse categorical cross
entropy so all of them they have cross
entropy
in them so they use this
cross entropy approach but
each one of these three
loss functions uses it
differently and for us
here we're gonna use
categorical cross entropy and we're
gonna use spas categorical cross entropy
and i'll show you what's the difference
between them
so here
let me start by
using
catigorical
cross entropy
and i'll explain a little bit later
do we why would you want to use
categorical and why would you want to
use sparse categorical
for now let me just finish this part
here for compiling our model so for the
metrics which is the last argument here
we need to set a metric for which the
uh basically we're going to guide our
training
so that our model knows that it's
becoming better or worse so here usually
for classification
we would use the accuracy so the
accuracy represents how many
examples are we predicting correctly
from all of the examples that exist in
the data sets so let's say you have a
data set of 100
examples
let's say images
and when you do the prediction
prediction
you get
let's say
88 images
correct
and the rest are incorrect in this case
the accuracy would be 88 over 100 which
is
88
this means the accuracy is 88
so this means that your model
makes a good prediction 88 of the time
so if now we have a thousand images and
around 880 images will be
correctly predicted
so for classification this is what we
would need as a metric
and of course here i am using the
usual
values that are used in classification
but there's a lot of advanced things
that you can do for example you can
create your
uh your own loss function your own
optimizer your own metrics and then you
can pass it here as a parameter but this
is a little bit advanced so for now i'm
just gonna
go through the steps with the usual
values that are used in the deep
learning community so now that we have
compiled our model
the only thing that's left is to
fit the data
into our model so for that we're going
to call model fit
and the fit function
uh takes several
uh parameters
the first parameter is the
x strain so the uh the images and then
it's gonna take the y train so the
labels corresponding to those images
it's also going to take a batch size
so this batch size represents
how many images
is our model going to see each time
so
here you can for example if you set it
to one this means that we're gonna pass
one image
uh
at a time to our model but
we usually don't do this we usually
choose a larger number of images to pass
them through our model so here for
example we can use 64.
this is also one of the hyper parameters
that you can change and see
how your model will perform
based on different
and also we're gonna
set the parameter epochs here
and let's say i'm gonna choose
for example
only three epochs so that we can quickly
do some experimentation
and the epoch represents
one epoch in fact represents
that the fact that your model has seen
all of your data set once so when all of
your images are passed through the model
if they're if this is done once then
this is one epoch
if
your model has seen them twice
then these are two epochs so on and so
forth so
basically here we're defining the number
of times that your model is going to
look at all of your data sets
this is also a hyper parameter
so
here in fact we can keep it just like
this and we can run the training which
means that all of the images that exist
in the train set are going to be used
for training
but
one thing that
that you can do in fact is use a
validation
split
so
a validation split here for example
let's say i'm going to use 0.2 this
means that i want to use 20
of the train images for validation
so again what would what does validation
mean what what is it why is it different
than the test set
for example
in fact in the when doing cross
usually you split your data into
the train
the
validation
and the test sets split them into these
three parts
the train
set will be used to train the model the
validation will be used at the end of
every epoch we're gonna run
the model on the validation not for
training but just for prediction so that
we can see how well the model is doing
on data that it did not see
it did not use to train
so these in fact these two splits
are the ones we use to fine tune our
our model so when i mentioned hyper
parameters i mentioned that this for
example hyperparameter this is a hyper
parameter the values here are hyper
parameters but when do you say that
one
or a set of hyper parameters is better
than another set of hyper parameters in
fact you do this using the validation
split
so whenever you train you test on the
validation split
or on the validation part and then you
see whether that
metric that you're using has improved or
not so in our case the metric is the
accuracy is the accuracy uh becoming
better when we change the hyper
parameters so you do one training with a
set of training parameters
you see the validation set is it good or
not
and then you change the hyper parameters
you run the training again and you look
at the validation
accuracy did it become better they
become worse
and you keep doing uh this loop of
experimentation until you get to a point
where you see that you're not
improving anymore on the validation set
and then
only when you're done with this
experimentation phase that you keep the
final model that works well on the
validation set and then you test it on
the test set
so
with this parameter here validation
splits what we're gonna do is
split our training set
into two parts eighty percent of the
training
images or the images that exist in this
uh
extreme variable are going to be used
for training and 20 of them are going to
be used for validation
and then we're going to keep the tests
set here until the end when we finish
the training
and we're going to use it to
evaluate our model to see how well it
performed on images that it has never
seen
so
the
images here whether they are in the
train set or the validation set
the model is gonna see them at some
point during the training but the test
set we're not gonna use it in this
function here which means that the model
will never see it during the training
and is we can
uh we can pass that set of images to the
model only at the end of the training so
for example we can pass it here
model that
evaluate and we can give it the
x test
apply test and
we can also
choose a batch size here let's just keep
it
the same as before
so
again just to summarize quickly what
we're doing here we're taking the
train images so 60 000
images we're gonna split them into two
parts eighty percent of the images so
eighty percent of the sixty thousand
images is going to be used for training
the rest which is 20 is going to be used
for validation
[Music]
and
the train set or the test says sorry
which is the 10 000 images here are
going to be used at the end when the
model has finished training so
at this point here
this is
model training
once this
line here is done then the model is
trained and here we can do
evaluation on test set
this set here the x test
is going to help us
identify how well our model is going to
perform on data that it has never seen
because usually what you do is you train
a model
you put it in production and then you
start testing it on new data that's
coming from for example your users if
you have some sort of a web product
and those examples the model has never
seen them
so
in order to get an idea of how well your
model will perform on examples like that
you keep this part here separate from
the training and the validation you keep
it until the end and then at the end you
test your model on it
so this is the goal of this test set and
the the goal of splitting the
this set here into two parts
now we have a complete program that we
can run and we can train our model
and we can see how well it performs on
train validation and test sets so let us
do that right now let me just clear this
and i'm gonna run our example here
so this might take some time depending
on your machine
but usually it shouldn't take that long
well in fact when i ran the code i got
into this error here and
in fact i wanted you to see this error
because it's a very common error and
uh i wanted to use it in order to
explain to you why you would want to use
categorical cross entropy
or sparse cross entropy in fact this
error is coming from uh from this
specific detail here
so when you have
a data set like we have here if you use
categorical cross entropy
then
in fact this loss function is going to
expect
your
labels which are these ones uh the
[Music]
x the y train and the y test is going to
expect them to be one heart encoded
and if you don't want to use one heart
encoding then you need to use a
different loss function which is the
sparse categorical cross entropy
so this is a minor detail but it's very
important
so if you go in fact to the
documentation
so here in the documentation i just
opened uh
the two pages for categorical cross
entropy and for sparse categorical cross
entropy
so for the categorical cross entropy
here although uh
it's not specifically mentioned here
but in fact if you look at the example
you see that
this is how you would use categorical
cross entropy these this this is how
your labels need to be set so in fact
this is
one label for one image
which is in the form of a vector
and in that vector
the one will correspond to the right
class and the zeros will correspond to
the wrong classes so if you have three
classes then
you need to set one to the right class
and zeros for the rest in our case
if we wanted to do one hot encoding then
for example if you have
let me just do this quick example here
if you have
label
two
then
[Music]
one hat
encoding will be like this
it will be a vector of
0
0
1
then 0 0 0
and 8 9 10.
this will be the corresponding label for
that
for that image so the image contains the
number two but your label needs to be
like this
and this is called
one hot encoding of your labels
now uh
if in the case
uh how we're using our data set in fact
we're not using
one hot encoding so our labels are just
encoded as numbers so if it's the second
if it's number two then the
corresponding label is two if it's zero
then it's zero so on and so forth we're
not using one-half encoding
so if you use
categorical cross-entropy
then you have to use one-half encoding
which means that you have to take the
y train y test and turn them into one
hot encoded
labels
and if you don't want to do that you
need to add the
sparse categorical entropy here instead
of the categorical
cross entropy because if you go to the
documentation
you look at the sparse categorical
cross entropy you see here that we're
using labels in the format of the normal
format
not the one using one hat encoding
so when doing this
if we save this
let me clear this again if i run my
example now we should have no problems
everything should be running smoothly
and as you can see the training has
started here and let me just stop it
here just to show you
uh if you were to use categorical cross
entropy what would you have what would
you need to do differently
because sometimes you might have a data
set that already has
one hot encoding labels
in that case
if you just want to use them as they are
you don't want to
transform your labels into a different
format
in that case you would just use
categorical cross entropy but if you
have labels like this that are not one
hot encoded and you want to turn them
into one hat
encoded
what you can do is
use
a utility from uh tensorflow
so here we're gonna do y train
[Music]
tensorflow.keras.utils.2
categorical
and then you would give it
y
the same uh array so y train and then
you want to tell it how many classes you
have so we have 10 classes between 0 and
9
and you would do the same for the y test
tensorflow keras
details
2
categorical
and here i want to give it test and 10
classes
so now if i do this
then in fact i'm transforming my labels
into one hot encoded labels and in that
case i can use categorical cross entropy
so
let's run the training again and see if
this works or not
so as you can see the training has
started correctly with no problems
and i hope now you understand
differences between categorical cross
entropy and sparse cross
sparse categorical cross entropy and
when to use which
so i'm gonna wait for the training to
finish i've only set
the epoxy 3
because it already gives us some
good
metrics here
and it's done
so let's go a little bit over the logs
here and i would like to explain to you
what these things mean
so
this one here the first number here 11
seconds represents how much how much
time we spent uh doing this one epoch
and also this tells us the speed so
12 milliseconds per step and the step
here means doing
a full badge so we have a badge of 64
images
so where the model is processing 64
images at the same time
in 12 milliseconds
and
by doing that the first epoch we got a
training loss so this loss here is the
training loss of 0.2368
we have an accuracy of around 93
we have a validation loss of
0.0994
and we have a validation accuracy of
around 97
and what this means is that
as you remember we did this split here
validation split so
the
first loss and accuracy are reported
based on the 80
of
the data that we use for training
and
this part here for the validation is
reported based on the 20
that we left out for the validation so
it's 20 of that extreme
and after each epoch we get these values
so that we can see the development of
the loss and the accuracy and what you
want to get here is a lower loss during
the training and a higher accuracy
and at the end this last line here we've
actually ran it over the
test set
just to see how well our
model our final model that we got here
how well
is it doing on
the
test set and here we see that we got a
98.36
accuracy which is not bad on this task
so as you can see now we have a full
program that
has a deep learning model
and it compiles that model with specific
optimizer loss metrics and then it fits
the data into that model and when we're
doing evaluation we're getting some good
results
so
with this we have finished the
first let's say a part of doing
training for an image classification
task and as you can see
it with tensorflow it makes so many
things easier you don't have to do a lot
of things you just need to set the right
parameters and prepare your data set in
the right
way
so
now that we have this uh first version
of our program working let's see what we
can do next
this first model that we created and we
trained was using the sequential
approach here where we just stacked
different layers
and now let's take a look at the
other approach that we can use which is
the functional approach
so first let me just maybe
change this
to
sequential
model just changing the name here
and
here what we want is to build the same
exact architecture but in the functional
approach
so in fact to do this
you just need to create a function
and let's call it for example functional
model
and
here you need to use
these same
same layers that we used in our
sequential model
but we're gonna use them in a
functional way
so let us just maybe copy them from here
and
just
paste them here
let me fix the indentation
and in order to build a model
using the functional approach what you
need to do is
basically
define a
set of layers and each time you need to
pass the output of the previous layer to
as an input to the new layer so here for
example i would call this my input
and then for
the convolution 2d i need to actually
pass my
input
as
as a parameter to
this convolution 2d and then i need to
store this into a variable
and i need to do this for the rest of
the layers so each time i have an output
of a layer i need to pass it as an input
to the
upcoming layer so let me just do this
quickly here
so
now i have done exactly what i explained
to you i'm just
using each time the variable x to store
the output of a certain layer then i'll
pass that variable as an input to the
next layer and i do this for all the
layers oops i've got this one here
and
okay we have it here here we have it
everywhere
and now
when you finish doing this
you need to basically create the model
where you tell it that this is the input
and this is the output
so the input is this and each time we're
passing it to our layers and we're
getting an output here which is x
but in order to construct a deep
learning model that you can call the
compile function and the fix the fit
function on it you have to
use
the
tensorflow.keras.model
class
and here you need to give it
inputs
and it's going to be my input
and also
outputs which is going to be x
and then you
return
your model
so this is how you would build
a deep learning model architecture using
the functional approach so as you can
see it's the same exact model
it's just that we're building it
differently
now why would you use this approach
rather than this sequential approach
well in fact the sequential approach is
rarely used when you're building
deep learning models
for some
let's say complex
tasks and even for smaller tasks i think
it's if it's uh it's better to build
your model in this way here because it's
much more
flexible you can do so many things for
example if you have let's say two
different inputs you can just set them
here this will be a list
of inputs where you just add the inputs
to it the same thing if you have several
outputs so it's a lot more flexible
i think
and also it's going to allow you to
for example you can build one part of
the model then create another part and
use those two parts into
when building a larger deep learning
model so this is a much better approach
in my opinion i've only seen the
sequential approach here used in some
tutorials online because it's easy
and it's basically allows you to quickly
build something
that you can
manipulate but
for
real world projects i think that using
this functional approach is much more
recommended so now that we have this
we can just go to our code here
sorry let me just close this here
here i'm just gonna call
my function so model
functional
[Music]
model
and then
i'm just gonna call the same exact
methods on it so the compile method the
fit method the evaluate method
and what's also good about this
functional approach is that you can make
this
uh
this
architecture much more flexible for
example
by uh
adding parameters to your function that
you later add them here for example the
number of filters here the
uh the filter size here you just add
them all as parameters here and then you
can generate
several models quickly you can just
create for example a for loop
and you create
several models with different hyper
parameters and then you compile them and
fit them and compare between them so as
you can see this would be
a good use case for functional model
instead of using sequential model so now
that we have this let's
run our code again and see if this works
or not so let me just run this
so the training should start and it did
so as you can see we have just defined
the same architecture in a different
approach which is the functional
approach
and it's working
well
the loss is going down the accuracy is
going up
and let's just wait for it to finish
this should not take long it's going to
run the evaluation on the test set here
and as you can see we got the
uh
the results here from our functional
model and there was no problem during
the training
uh or the evaluation
so this is the second approach that you
can use to build deep learning models
the third and last approach is by using
or by inheriting from the
tensorflow.kerastat model class and
which is what we're gonna do next
to build a deep learning model
architecture using this third approach
you start by
creating a class you can give it any
name you like so for me i'm just gonna
call it my custom
model
and then you need to inherit from the
class
tensorflow.keras.model and in python to
do that you just add parentheses and you
have the class that you want to
inherit from
so
here model
let's start with the instructor here
and here we're calling it on the uh
the mother class which is this class
here
let me just maybe remove this we don't
need to use it
and now
what you would do and
in this third approach is that you need
first to define all of the
layers and you need to give them a name
and then
you would use the
or you would
call the function
in fact implement the function call
which is
just like this and then you can give it
your
input
and then
here what you would do is you would pass
your input
throughout your layers here so you start
with the first layer and then you
continue so to make this more clear let
me just
do this here first we're gonna define
all the layers and again i'm going to
use the exact same architecture
and just
we're implementing it in three different
ways so that you can compare between the
uh three approaches
so here i'm just gonna start by
creating these layers and give it giving
them names
so here i have just done exactly that
as you can see i call my first
convolutional layer
self.com1 cell.com2 so on and so forth
and here
when i go to my call function here i can
start calling them
so
my input
needs to be passed through this first
layer and then the output of it needs to
be passed to the second layer so on and
so forth so this is what the call method
here needs to do so
let me just do this quickly now
[Music]
so i have just finished doing exactly
that i just
i take my input i passed it to my com1
cell.com1 layer which is this
convolutional 2d
and then i get an output then i pass it
to the second one so on and so forth and
at the end i need
to return x
and
this might look a little strange this
approach compared to the other ones
but this is also one of the approaches
you can use to build custom models
especially if they're
much more complex than than this you can
do so many things when you have a class
specific for your
for your tensorflow model
and in fact if you've worked with
pytorch before then this should be very
familiar to you because
it's very similar to what pytorch does
in pytorch you do the same thing you
define the layers first and then
there is a method
i think it's forward if i'm not mistaken
instead of call and then you do the same
thing you pass the input
to the first layer and then the output
to the next layer so on and so forth
so
we're doing this with in fact we just
finished uh defining our model using
this third approach and we can
use it
to
in the practically the same manner we
used the functional and the sequential
model so let's see how we can do this
so i'm just gonna comment this one here
and now instead of using my functional
model i'm just gonna use
my custom model
so just calling
or instantiating an object from my
custom model class
i get my model and then i can do exactly
the same thing i can compile my model i
can fit my model i can evaluate my model
and let's test this quickly here
let me run the example again
so
okay it says okay now the training is
running and as you can see uh
we're doing the exact same thing as we
did with the first two approaches
and
now you have seen the three different
approaches used when creating an
architecture for a deep learning model
and tensorflow
and you can use whatever you like
you can also use them all three
depending on the task that you're doing
and depending on the
specific circumstances
but here as you can see we defined the
same architecture in three different
approaches and we were able to fit the
data and evaluate our model and the
results are
very close
so
now
you have all of these uh these
tools and these approaches that you've
learned
and we use them on the amnest
data set let's see now what we can do
next
so there are some things that i omitted
in this first tutorial here
i just wanted i wanted to only show you
the main parts that you need when
training a deep learning model
but
in fact you can do a lot more things and
there are some necessary parts that i
didn't mention here so for example one
thing is about saving the model
so here we're just doing the training
and evaluating the model but we're not
saving anything so what if i want to use
this trained model in production what if
i want to use it in some sort of a web
app or an embedded application
in that case i would need a model that i
can take and then i can
run in a separate script that just loads
the model and makes predictions with it
something else that i didn't do
is
saving the best model during the
training so there's one thing you can do
here we just saved the final model but
if you notice here for example let's see
if we have a good example
uh
yes okay so you see this second
step here
we have a higher accuracy than the last
epoch
so it's actually better to save this
model
that was uh finalized in this epoch
rather than the last model
with which was uh
saved or it wasn't safe but which we got
at the third epoch
so we're not doing this now we're not
saving the best model we're not saving
any model in fact
i wanted to show you this in this
tutorial but then i thought it would be
better if we leave this
in the next tutorial that i'll show you
which will represent a real world uh
scenario because
here with the amnest examples which are
the hello world equivalent in
programming
you have the amnest data set already
prepared for you you see we just used it
as part of the tensorflow
framework so we're just loading it and
then
we are using these
these images and labels
when training our model but if you're
working on a real world
case then maybe you would
maybe you would have
collected images by yourself maybe you
went outside and
captured some images here and there so
in that case you need to
create your own data set
that is compatible with tensorflow and
that you can use it to train a deep
learning model that you would define
just like we did here
so
i wanted to leave these
details of saving the model during the
training and saving the final model
the format of saving the model i wanted
to leave them for the next tutorial that
we're gonna do
so
with this first tutorial you should have
all the uh necessary
steps that you would use to train a deep
learning model for classification
uh many of these
or most of them in fact most of these
uh parameters most of these things that
we've done here we're gonna redo that in
the next tutorial
but just we're gonna go into maybe more
details about specific things like the
data set uh how to create a data set
that you can use just like the keras or
or just like the amnes data that sorry
how to save the model during the
training
how to save the final model in the saved
model format
and things like that
so for now this is it for this tutorial
and let's take a look next at what we
can do in a real case scenario
so before we continue along the course
let's maybe restructure a little bit our
code for better readability this is
something that you're gonna find
yourself doing often when you're
developing projects for uh for a company
that you're working for
and in
by doing this you're actually gonna make
your life easier in the future because
you're gonna have all of these different
modules that contain different parts of
the code and
many of them will be reusable modules so
that you can use them in other projects
as well
so
the first thing we're going to do is
maybe move these two models the
functional model and the
the model that inherited from this class
into a different
file so for that let me just create a
new file and maybe just call it
deep learning
models dot by
and what i'm going to do here is just
move
these
parts of the code
so
let me just move these
ctrl x
and
control v
and here
i can just
import the same
modules or the same
functions and classes that
we used
in our code
and also
i'm gonna
import
of course
tensorflow because we're using it
here
and by this we're gonna have our
models in a separate file and then we
can just come to
our main script and do for example
from
deep learning models import
functional model
and also my custom model
so as you can see we moved large part of
the code
into another file and now we have this
file here that just contains the deep
learning models so
maybe we can use these models in a
different projects and we will find them
in a separate file instead of
finding them in this script that's
specifically made for
mnist data set
another thing we can do for example is
move this
function here display some examples to a
different file so maybe
we can call it for example my
utils
dot by
and
also okay let me close this
i'm gonna come here and just
cut this
and paste it
here
and here of course i'm gonna have to
import
mad
plotlib dot pi
plot
as plt
and also i need to import
port
numpy
as
mp
so now we have this and of course
we can import our functions
the same way from
my utils import
display some examples
and now as you can see a large part has
been moved from this file and now this
file is specifically made for the amnest
data set and we're importing the
necessary
models and functions from
our other files that we just created so
i am showing to showing you this here
just as an example that you can use
for your projects because
when you're working for a company and
you're building
ai projects machine learning models
you're going to find yourself doing lots
of experimentation you're going to find
yourself reusing parts of your code so
if you get used to this
habit of taking uh different parts of
the code that are reusable and putting
them into separate files this is going
to help you a lot uh and your future
self is gonna thank you
and with this uh that would be it for
the coding of this first tutorial let's
see what we can do next
so let's just recap what we have seen in
this first tutorial
so basically we took a look at the
amnest data set
we saw how we can load it from the
tensorflow data sets
we explored that data set by
implementing a function that can go
through the data set and randomly choose
some images with their corresponding
labels
we took a look at the tensorflow layers
how to import them and then we saw how
we can use those layers to build a
neural network architecture
in three different approaches the
sequential way the functional way and by
inheriting from the model class
at the end we compiled our model and fit
the data
and we finished the tutorial by
restructuring our code for better
readability
so with this this would be the end of
this first tutorial let's see what we
can cover next
welcome to this second part or second
tutorial in this introductory tensorflow
course
so
in this tutorial
what we want to achieve is something
like the following
so we're going to have a data set of
traffic signs like the ones you see here
and the goal would be to develop a deep
learning model that can take an image of
a traffic sign like this one and then it
gives us at the output that this image
actually corresponds to the traffic sign
of speed limit 100 kilometers
per hour
and
maybe it will not tell us exactly this
expression here but maybe it can tell us
that it's one and that one corresponds
to this speed limit uh 100 kilometers
per hour and if we try if we change the
traffic sign we want to get the
corresponding
sign here so we're going to be
developing
and building and training this deep
learning model
and this will be the goal of this second
tutorial
the data set that we will be using for
this tutorial is called german traffic
sign recognition benchmark
so this data set you can find it on
kaggle so if you don't know the website
kaggle it's a website that many data
scientists machine learning engineers
and just anyone who's interested in
machine learning uses it because it has
so many data sets it also has some
competitions that you can join and you
can even be part of a team and you can
learn a lot by doing that
so
this data set in order for you to get it
you can go to this
link here and if it's maybe the link is
not that clear since we see so many meow
meow here you can just
take the german traffic sign recognition
benchmark
expression here and you can
look it up
let me just maybe go back to make it
clear so if you're on the kaggle website
you're gonna go here on the search bar
type this and look it up and it should
be the first result
and then you're gonna get to the same
page that i showed you earlier
just a quick note here so in order for
you to get access to the data set and
download it you need to have an account
on kaggle it's completely free i already
have one and i'm already logged in
but if you don't have an account you can
just
create a an account for free and then
you can
continue with
going to the data set page and download
it
so in order to download the data set you
just click on the button download
and then it's gonna download it to your
own machine
and
once it's downloaded it's going to be a
zipped folder like this and then you can
unzip it in order to get
a set of files and folders like this
just a quick note here also
when i was
unzipping this folder here i realized
that
i think the data set is
duplicated
so
many files it asked me that whether i
want to replace them or just keep both
versions when i was
unzipping this file here
i chose to
replace them
so that i don't have a duplicate of
every file and every folder in my data
set
i think this is
maybe a mistake that was done by the
person who
collected or put the data set on kaggle
but it's not a big deal you can just
unzip the folder and when it asks you
whether
there are new files and folders that
have the same name just choose replace
or choose do not replace for the rest of
the data set and that way you won't have
any duplicated folders and files
and now that we have it here and as you
can see i unzipped it
we see that we have
three files and three folders
so the main files and maybe the main
folders that we're gonna be looking at
are the tests
and train folders and also the
test.csv
file
so let's first go to the train folder
here
so as you can see we have
43 folders of from 0 to 42 so 40 43
folders and in each folder we have
images
that belong to the same class let me see
if this is the large let's see i is the
same okay
so for example we can see here that this
is a sign for
the
traffic sign that says
there's a speed limit of 20 kilometers
per hour
we also have
this data set here
of the speed limit 50
and we have all sorts of
speed signs as you can see
and what i really like about this data
set
is that
the images represent real life cases now
not like the amnest example where
the data set is more or less already
prepared for us
but
in the case of these traffic signs we
see that these
signs are taken into in uh different
luminosity levels uh different light
levels
uh it also comes in different sizes so
different images have different sizes
they're not all the same
and also if we go to the next folder
which is the test folder
here you can see that we have a set of
images
and we can't know just from the name for
example whether this image belongs to
class 1 2 or whatever so we can't know
from
just looking at the image and looking at
the name of the image in order for us to
know uh each image belongs to which
class we need to go and look at the
csv file corresponding to that folder so
test.csv for the test folder
and let me just open it here
okay let me close this
so here as you can see in the
test.csv file
we have a
different lines corresponding to
different images each line has
these width and height of the image also
has a roy area i guess it's a more
tightened area around the
traffic sign
we also have the name of the image
and we have the id of the image
and these are the
two most important
information that we need from this so we
need the path and we for each image we
need to know the corresponding class
idea so
here let me just maybe
open this
close so let's go to the test
so for example the first image
000.png
it says that this belongs to class
number 16. this is the class id so
it's 16
and if we want to just quickly verify
uh just remember this is uh i think a
traffic sign that says
the trucks cannot pass through here
or only for trucks i can't remember
honestly
and if i go to the train set and i go to
class 16
as you can see it corresponds to the
right class
so
from with what we see here we have
two folders
the first one for training
the second one for the test set the test
set is not organized like the train set
uh in order for us to know which image
belongs to which label we have to look
at the csv file
and there's also the fact that we only
have two sets so there's only the train
and test set
but in reality what you want to have
when you're developing deep learning
models for real life cases you want to
have three sets you want to have a train
set a validation set and a test set
so there is a lot of work
to be done before we can train a deep
learning model on this data set
and
this tutorial for me represents a much
more
mature case of uh much of a machine
learning project where
basically you are using a real-life data
set
if someone collects it maybe uh he
chooses to
annotate the data set like this where it
just puts the images in one folder and
keeps a csv file corresponding to those
images and their labels so as you can
see it's not very clean not like the
case where we had the amnes data set we
just basically loaded it so now in order
to build a deep learning model on
this data set we have to
basically
do some cleaning and also some
preparation of this data set and this is
exactly what we're going to be doing
next
so the first thing we're going to do now
to prepare our data set for training
is
to
go to this
train folder
and we're going to split this
data set here that exists in this folder
into two different folders one for
training and one for validation
so basically what we want to do is to
create some function that can go through
all of these folders and each time
it goes through the images in every
folder and it takes part of them and
puts them in a training folder and the
rest it puts them in the validation
folder
so let's start by uh coding this
and before that let me just maybe add
a new script we're going to call it
street
signs
example that buy
[Music]
so this will be for all the necessary
code
to basically
load the data set and uh also train the
model and evaluate it
and here
maybe let's first start by defining a
function
that's gonna split the data so let's
call it
split data
and what this function is going to take
is the path to the data so the original
folder
which is
this one here we're going to take a look
uh or we're gonna look into this folder
here and then we want to split the data
into
a training folder so that to
maybe let's call it say train and also
path to
save
valve for validation
and we're also gonna choose a split size
and it's going to be between
zero and one
and i'm just going to give it a default
value of
0.1 and what i want is
for 90 of the data to be put in the
training folder
and the rest which is 10
it's gonna be put inside the save for
the the validation folder
so here
let me
come here and
the first thing we're gonna do is
basically get the folders
so i'm gonna use os dot
list deer and i'm gonna give it the path
to data
and since we don't have this module let
me import it here
so what
this uh
line here is going to do is basically
it's going to give us a list of all the
folders that exist inside this directory
here
and then what i want to do is to
iterate through the folders so i'm gonna
do for
folder
and
folders
and here first i want to get the path
to
or maybe let me call it
full
path
which is going to be the path
or the full path to the directory so
here
we're gonna have this path
and then this first command here is
going to give us the folders now we want
to concatenate the name of the folder
with this
path here in order to get the full path
to
this set of images for example or this
set of
images so here i'm gonna use
os.path
dot join
and we're just gonna use
the path to data and also i'm gonna
concatenate that with the folder
after that what i want to get
is a
list of all the paths to the images
inside that folder so i'm going to call
it images paths and for this i'm going
to use the module globe
so it doesn't exist here so let me just
import glob here so this module is going
to allow me to look inside a folder and
load
all of the
files that exist in that folder
depending on an extension that i
choose
so
here what i want to do is
use os dot pat dot join
and i want to join the full pad that i
just constructed
and also i only want to load the
images so
our images let me just take a look
quickly all of our images have a png
extension so i only want to load png
files
so here
by doing this what i'm what i'm saying
is that i'm telling this glob module to
give me a list of all the files that
have extension
png
inside my
inside this
folder here full path so
now we have a list of all the images
inside that folder
and what we can do now is
we can for example to extrane
and
x val
and we want to
basically split the data set into these
two different parts and for that there's
actually a utility function
called
train
test
split
which we can import from
the
scikit-learn module
so here if i do
from
scikit-learn
dot
model selection
import
train test
split
so by doing this i'll be able to use
this
train test split
function here and what this function
takes
is
basically the images pads
images pads and also
it's gonna take the
test size
so this is going to be the fraction that
represents the number of images that we
want to put inside
this
variable here
and for this i'm just going to use
my split
size which i pass here as an argument so
what i'm what i'm saying here is that
please split all of uh the the please
split the list of all of the images here
into two parts
train and val for validation and i want
this second part to be only
uh this fraction of the data set which
is uh
if we keep the value as it is then it's
going to be 10
and if we call the function and we
change this split size
then it's going to take that exact
fraction
so
now we have
our
train and
validation
pads and what we can do now is basically
just go through them
so first we're gonna go through for
so for x in
x trains
so we're going through all of the images
that were selected for the train set
and the first thing we're going to do is
get the name
of the image and in order to get that
we're just going to use the
function
os dot pad dot base name
and we're gonna give it
x as
the argument here and was remember this
x represents a full path here we want to
get just the name of the image
so we would like for example to get this
only this uh five zeros five zeros five
zeros dot png so this is what we can i'm
gonna get as the base name
and then we're gonna use
basically the space name to reconstruct
a new path
that
points to this path here and is we're
going to save our image inside this path
here so let us first do
this
folder i'm going to construct a
path here os.path dot
join
[Music]
and i'm gonna do
path
to save
train
and folder
so here what i'm doing is
uh imagine that for example i want to
save my
images into this
let's create a new folder for example
and let's call it
[Music]
training
data
and inside of this i'm going to create a
folder called train
and another call another folder called
val for validation
so
what i'm going to do is
take
the images from folders like this
and just go for example to the train set
or the train folder and just put that
image here
and for now i'm just going to copy the
images i'm not going to move them just
so that i keep the original data set as
it is but first here i need to add a
folder for example one
two three that responds to that
specific
label for that image and that's why what
we're doing here is we're constructing
this
full path here
so this is going to be
this path
and then we're gonna add
a
folder with the same name as the folder
that we found in the original data set
here
and after that
what we're gonna do is check
if
this
folder does not exist
so path to folder
sorry if not
os dot
path dot his
directory
so this is gonna check whether this
folder exists or not if it doesn't exist
we're gonna create one what's that make
theirs so this is to create
that folder and i'm gonna do that to
folder
so this part here just checks whether
that folder exists or not if it doesn't
it creates that folder
and now what we're gonna do is use the
you the utility module sh
util
and i don't have it imported so i'm
gonna import it here
sh
util
[Music]
and this module here gives me access to
several functions
one of them is the copy function that i
can use and now what i can do is
basically copy my image
and put it inside a new
directory that i just
constructed here and if it didn't exist
i would have already created it here
and now i want to put my image inside
this folder so
what we can do is actually two things
now that i'm looking at it we can either
do path to folder and this is going to
copy the image with the exact
name that it has inside this folder or
we can construct
a complete directory with the
name of that image
so basically we don't need this here is
in fact just going to take the name of
the image and
put it inside the new folder so this is
going to be for the train set and we're
going to do the same thing for the
validation set
so i have just added the
part here for the validation and this is
going to be identical to the train set
the only thing i'm doing is looking at
the original
directory
going through the folders constructing a
new folder
inside the train and the validation
folders and then copying that image from
the original
data set or the original folder into the
corresponding folder whether it's strain
or validation
and now that we have this let's test our
function
and i have also here
activated the virtual environment that
we used before which is tf2vn
and in order to do that you can just
point to the folder where you have
anaconda 3 installed on your machine
uh in order to use the script called
activate and then point to the name of
the
environment that you have and also
something that
may be
a quick way to do this
let me
just clear this first in fact if you're
on visual studio code and if you have
already used a specific virtual
environment with anaconda before then
what i have noticed is that if you click
on the plus sign here is going to open a
new terminal and also is going to
activate that
environment
automatically so you can use this
quick way
to
activate your virtual environment
and now that we have
this
uh
let me maybe first
activate or
save my script here and one thing you
can notice is that
this script or this module scalene is
not recognized
and
uh just to reiterate what i showed you
in the first tutorial if you click on
control shift p you can choose the right
interpreter and here i'm making sure
that i am using the same virtual
environment so it's tf2 vm
and this module is not installed inside
this virtual environment so for that you
can do a quick pip install scaler for
scikit-learn and this is going to
install that
module if it's not already installed
and once this is done
then here we can
do the same thing as with before so if
name
equals
main
[Music]
then i would like to do a set of things
here
so
i'm gonna do
uh i'm gonna
basically choose the paths
that i want in order for me to split my
data set
so the first path needs to be
towards my
original set which is this one so i'm
gonna do this ctrl c
and here i'm gonna paste it
i'm just gonna add
[Music]
these
uh backwards slashes here just so that i
don't get any problem and if you are on
linux machine i believe that this is
a safe way so that
you don't face any problems because
between windows and linux they handle
paths differently but if you do
two backward slashes like i'm doing here
then you shouldn't face any problem
so this is the path to data and then
path to save
train
so this is going to be the path where i
want to save the
train part so
i want
to save it here
ctrl
c ctrl v and let me
fix these as i have done before
very quickly okay
and then i want
to
basically paste the same path here so
path to
save
valve
and
let me paste it except that it's going
to point to the valve folder
which is
this one here
so now that we have our three different
folders
or paths we can call our function called
split data
so it's going to take
path to
data
path
to
save
train let me just make sure that i'm
using
to save train and also path
to
save
valve as path
to save val
and for the split size we can keep it as
it is so we don't have to call it here
and let me just save my script
let me clear my terminal so the goal is
to
copy the
images from the original
folder into these two folders and it's
going to put 90 of those images in the
train folder and 10
in the validation folder so let me run
this script quickly
and see if it works without any problems
so here
it's gonna
this module should be installed so there
should be no problem here and now the
script is actually running it's just
that we don't see
uh we don't see it work because we don't
print anything but if we go here you see
that it started to construct these
folders
in both
the train and validation folder
and in each one we should have a set of
images like it's shown here
so this might take a little bit of time
because we have a lot of images
at the end i'll show you what we get and
all the images that were copied we're
gonna see that they have been correctly
copied with the correct split size that
we chose
so now the script has finished and the
program has finished working
and if we look at our data here
we see now that in my training folder i
have 43 folders and the same for the
validation folder
and in fact if we check
quickly the number of images
here we see that in the train set we
have around 35 000 images
and in the validation set
we have around 4 000 images so that
sounds about right so the split size
seems to be correct
and if we go to every every folder we
have the exact same
uh
images that we had in the original
set which was this one here
so now we have
our training and validation sets
what we need is the test set
and as you remember the test set is
comprised of images like this and in
order for us to know
which label which basically which label
corresponds to that image we need to
look at the corresponding csv file
so for that let us create a function
that does this so our function is going
to take
as arguments the path to
the folder and the path to the csv file
and based on these two we're gonna
construct a folder that contains the
right images just like this so we want
to order our
test set so that it starts looking like
this folder here or these folders here
so let us get into this and maybe since
this is also a utility function maybe we
can just remove it from this main script
and
maybe add it to our
utilities script
and here
we need the os module so import os
so
and also import glob
import glob
and
finally the
scikit-learn
from
scikit-learn dot
model
selection
import
train tests later from numbers taken let
me check this
train test splits
this sounds
correct
and also we need the sh util
sage
util
so this these are the modules necessary
import
so these are the modules necessary to
run these functions and now here we
don't have that we can also remove these
if we want
for now i'm just going to keep them a
star problem and here i'm going to do
from
my utils
import split data
so this is
a much cleaned
a much cleaner script
and now let's
maybe do the same for the test set as i
mentioned so we want to build this
function that orders the test set so
let's call it
uh or maybe let's just code this
straight in the utilities
script here so i'm going to define a
function called
order test set
and what this function is going to take
as i mentioned
the path to the images and also
that to csv file
[Music]
or just csv is clear
and here what i want is to construct a
dictionary that basically
has the name of the image as
uh
as the key and also the corresponding
label
as
the as the value
so let's start by defining
our dictionary
and by the way this dictionary here is
just going to help us keep
track of the data set later if we want
but it's not really necessary for us
when we're just ordering the test set
i just prefer to do this so that i have
or i could have some sort of
a data structure that contains my image
paths and also their corresponding
labels
but for you it's not
it's not really necessary for
our ordering
part because as you remember we just
want
to go through these images
and just order them
like we have here
so here let me start by
creating a try block and what i'm going
to do here is to
open my csv file
so path
to csv
and the mode is read i don't want to
write
this inside this file i just want to
read
and i want to open it as csv file
and then
i can create a reader
and it's going to use the module csv
the reader
and since we don't have the module csv
we can import it here
and just maybe a quick note here
if you see me using module that's not
installed inside your virtual
environment then
it's very easy to install any module you
want you just run pip install the name
of that module
so here i'm gonna use
this function or this method here
and i'm gonna give it my csv file
[Music]
and also i'm gonna use
i'm gonna choose the delimiter to be
a comma here and why comma because
inside my csv file you see that these
elements are separated using a comma
and now
what i want to do is
basically go through all the rows that
exist in this reader because this reader
is going to contain
each row inside my csv file
including including in fact this first
row here that only contains information
so only the headers which we don't need
so we need to make sure that we don't
use that information in that first row
so that's why we're gonna do
for i row and
enumerate
reader
and the first thing i'm going to do is
check if
i'm looking at the first row and if i am
i'm just going to continue which means
that i don't want to use any information
in that row i just want to go to the
next one
and for the rest of the rows what we're
going to do is first get the image name
and for that what we can do is use our
row
and in fact our row is going to contain
all of the elements inside that row so
it's going to contain this value then
this and this this and you can access
them using the correct index so row 0 is
going to access this
value here and row
minus 1 for example is going to access
the last
element which is the path to the image
so here what i want to do is
get the image name so for that i'm gonna
get the final or the end value inside
that row
and remember that
each image here this is how the data set
was constructed so we have we don't just
have the name of the image we also have
this test
and forward slash next to it so we don't
want it we just want the name of the
image so for example the first one would
be zero zero zero zero zero dot png we
just want this we don't want this part
so what we what we're gonna do here is
since this is a string
we're gonna
use the method replace and i want to
replace
this string here with an empty string
this means that
we're gonna take
this
full
information we're gonna remove this and
we're just gonna keep the name of the
image
and the second thing we want to get is
the
label
so for the label
this is going to be row
minus 2 and that's because this is the
second element starting from the end so
this class id is the second element from
the end or it's zero one two three four
five six sixth element so
we're gonna
use this or you can do just this
for me i think this is much cleaner -2
because now i know just from the end i'm
just going to look at the second value
there
and then what we're going to do is
construct a path
to
folder and this is going to be a path
that
uh
[Music]
that is constructed using the path to
the images and also the label so add a
join
that
two images
and also
label since it's a string
and then i'm gonna check if
this path does not exist
that path that is directory
path
to folder if it doesn't exist i'm gonna
create it
and
here
i'm gonna do os dot
make deers
path
to folder
so this is
exactly what we did in the previous part
so i'm just redoing it here
and now what i want is
to move my
image
from the original
set so here
from the test set here i want to move it
into this new folder that corresponds to
the right label and you'll see in a
minute what i mean by this
so here i'm gonna do
image
full path
os.path dot join
path
to
images
image name
so i'm constructing a full path and then
i can do sh
util dot move
you can either copy or move the images i
showed you before
in the previous function here we
we copied it in this one split data and
now we're just gonna use the utility
function move
so
for this we're gonna move the image so
because we just got the full path to
that image and we want to move it into
the right folder which is path to folder
and
this would be it here
i'm gonna use the
accept command
so that if we can't open
the csv file
i'm gonna get a message here that lets
me know that we couldn't do that so for
that i'm just gonna do
print
and for example i'm gonna use
the info class
and i'm going to write
error
reading csv file
and if everything
goes
fine
at the end we're gonna
return
test data
well in fact since we're not using the
test data here we're not constructing
anything let me just maybe remove it
because
it's not going to add a lot of
information for us
so i'm just going to save this i'm going
to open the csv file read the necessary
information move the
images to a new folder that responds to
their labels
and
with this we will have
our images
in the right order
and now here what i'm going to do is
import my function so this order test
set
and again i'm going to use that
basically
trick that
i use
false
so that i deactivate parts of my code
and now we're gonna use or we're gonna
use our function that we just
constructed and remember we're gonna
have to give it the path to the images
and path to the csv so i'm gonna do path
two images
and this is going to be
this one here
ctrl
c
ctrl
v and let's go quickly
to our path here
and also we're gonna have to give it the
path to csv
and this is going to be
this one here
in fact for the test we can just click
shift
and then copy path
and we're going to get the full path
like this
so now we have
our path to the images we also have the
path to the csv file and then we can
call our
order test set function
and this function is going to take
that to
images and also path to csv
so if this function works correctly and
works as it's intended to do then now
what we should have is a set of folders
here that contain the right images we're
gonna move these images to their
corresponding folders
so let me
everything is saved okay let me run the
same script again
and again this might take a little time
because
we have a lot of images but if we take a
look at our folder as you can see it has
created all of these folders and now
it's moving the images you see their
numbers going down it's moving them to
the right folder
and with this
now we have our data set
in the correct format
and in fact when we added just a quick
note here when we added
the
part of
replace here it was necessary to add
this part because
here we have that
test part as
part of the image path and if we didn't
do this it would have given us an error
and now we have our data set for the
test set correctly uh
presented correctly ordered and now we
have a set of
data
or a set of folders that correct that
contain our data in a very good format
that we can use for training and testing
our model
and with this we have our data set ready
let's see what we can do next for
building our deep learning model and
doing all the fun stuff for deep
learning
let's start creating our deep learning
model
so
that we can fit our
traffic signs
data set that we just ordered and
prepared
so for that i'm gonna
open my deep learning models file
as you remember we have created this
file where we put all of our deep
learning models in it
and
i'm just gonna add at the end
i'm gonna create a new function
for our new deep learning model so in
the previous tutorial i showed you for
the amnes data set how to create a deep
learning model using three approaches
sequential way functional way and by
using
a class that inherits from the model
class but for this example since i have
already shown you the other three
approaches i'm just gonna use one
approach which is the functional way so
here i'm gonna create a new function
for my model i'm gonna call it
street
signs model
and what my function is going to take
is the
number of
classes as a parameter
and now let's start building our deep
learning model
so one thing to notice is that between
the amnes data set and the
science data set
so for the
science data set we have an rgb
we have rgb images so it's uh
we see we have blue
red we have all colors unlike the amnes
data set which was grayscale
data set
so now we need to take this into
consideration because when you have an
image that's
that has a
red blue and green this means it has
three channels if it's just
different layers of gray scales then in
this case it has only one channel
so why i'm mentioning this because for
our first
layer here which is the output layer
we're going to use as before the
input
layer that's imported here
and we're gonna have to give it a shape
so this shape here is gonna represent
the
width height and also the number of
channels for our images
so when looking at these images we see
that most of them are almost squared
shapes and here i checked a few
images
just to see the size and as you can see
this is 44 by 45 almost a square and
even the largest ones are still
in
squared form
and here we can see 80 by 84 almost
square as well and the same thing goes
for all of the
images in our data set
so
since these are
small images relatively small and
they're squared
i thought that using a size 60 by 60
would be a good choice
because i've seen some images that has
that had width and height
smaller than 60 and some of them a
little
higher than 60 so 60 by 60 is
an acceptable choice although you can do
something which sometimes i do which is
going through all of the images in the
data set computing the mean of the width
and the height and maybe even the median
and by looking at those values you can
have an idea about where the widths and
heights of the images in your data set
are lying so in that case you can
basically choose a good value for your
width and height and for your input
model like we're doing here
so here i'm going to choose 60 by 60 and
since we have rgb images i'm going to
choose three which is going to be
different than the first model where we
had one
and then since we have this we're just
going to do the same thing as we did for
the first model for the mnist data set
and i'm just going to do this quickly
here
so i have used the
the layers that we used before which is
convolution
max pooling batch normalization and i
use them in these blocks as you can see
these are basically similar blocks
each time i use a convolution followed
by max pool 2d then batch normalization
and here i have actually
i wanted to show you the difference
between
a layer called flatten and the global
average pool 2d layer
so first of all let me import this layer
here so it's flattening
so there's no problem
and also
let me get
the model
the model
function from
okay let's
find them here
it should be in the
[Music]
okay i can't see it
okay in that case let's just go here
and do from
tensorflow.keras
import
model
so this is what we're going to use here
so here i have commented this part
this is the same
layer that we used previously with the
amnes data set
and i told you that you can also use the
flatten layer here which is just going
to flatten all of the
uh the values that are coming from the
previous layer so in this case the batch
normalization
and what i wanted to do is to
basically
build this model and show it to you and
then we're gonna change this
layer to global average pool 2d
and i'm going to show you the new model
and then we're gonna look at the
difference between the two
so here
uh
basically we have our model and we can
import it from here so
from
deep learning models
import
street signs model and we can use it
here
and just something that i also do from
time to time when i'm doing
experimentations such as these ones
sometimes even in my
scripts that are not used in the main
script so these are scripts that just
contain some utility functions and
classes just like this script here
sometimes even in these scripts i do the
i create
basically part of my code
where
i can test things straight inside this
script so for example now what i wanted
to show you is
this model we're going to build it with
this layer flattened layer and then
we're going to build it with the global
average pool 2d layer and we're going to
see the difference there
so here i'm gonna do
model equals
street signs model and for now i'm just
gonna give it
uh whatever i want since this is not the
model that i'll be using with the data
set this is just for testing purposes
and what i want to do is to call
the
method summary
and this method is going to show us
the model architecture the different
layers inputs and outputs shapes so this
is going to help us get an idea of how
our
model looks like
so here
let me run this
python
[Music]
deep learning models dot by and as you
can see the the goal of these of this
part here this is gonna help us for
example when we're doing tests like i'm
gonna show you in a minute we can just
call this script here but if i import
this script in another script so for
example here i am importing this
function from my
script here in this case this part of
the code will not be called
so this is a good way to separate parts
where you just want to test something
quick and also the parts where you want
to reuse them in other scripts
so with this let me run this quickly
here
and let me maybe
put this like this
so this is
the architecture of our deep learning
model as you can see the the input is 60
60 by 3 and also we have
this first
uh value here represents the batch size
so none means that it can be any batch
size we want and then there is the
convolution 2d
the max pooling and so on and so forth
and when we come at the end here
we have the flattened layer as you can
see what the flattened layer has done is
that it took all the values from the
previous layer so here we have
uh basically a some sort of a cube where
you have five by five and it has a depth
of
128
and what it did is that just took all of
the values and put them in one vector
that's why we get 3200 because it's
equal to 5x5
by 128.
now
if let me let me change this to the
global average pooling instead and i'm
gonna comment this
so let me
run the same script again
[Music]
and also enlarge this part here
now
when we come to the layer here
so before you see we had the flattened
layer
third from the last layer so this is we
changed it with the global average
pulling 2d and now you see we don't have
3 thousand
and two hundred
because the global average pooling 2d
what it does is that it actually
computes the average in these
uh in
these windows here so imagine you have a
cube where it's 5 by 5 100 by 128 so
every 5 by 5 will compute the average
there so at the end we only we're only
left with 128 values
so this is the difference between those
two
layers i wanted to
show you how
basically reflect in the architecture
and whether you should use one or the
other it's actually one of the things
that you can experiment with just like i
mentioned in the first tutorial
when you're doing deep learning machine
learning in general you're going to be
doing lots of experimentation so this
could be one factor of your
experimentation where you change these
two different layers and see which ones
uh which one gives you the best results
so now we have our architecture ready
and we can
call it from our main scripts here and
we can compile the model and fit the
data so we're going to be doing this
next
in fact before we
compile our model and fit the data we
have to create what's called
data generators
so
data generators are actually going to
take the images from our data sets
folders so as you remember we have
train and validation
folders
and we also have the test folder that we
organized
so
now
we're going to use some uh basically
tensorflow utilities that help us
achieve this
very easily which is
one of the main points of tensorflow
i've been using tensorflow for some time
and
every
basically with every release there are
lots of
functionalities new features that make
your
building the model uh preparing the data
set makes all of this a lot easier
so here i'm going to create a utility
function again i'm inside my
myutils.by
file which i use to add all types of
utility function that i might use in the
future so
here i'm gonna define a function i'm
gonna call it create
generators
and basically my function is gonna take
uh some arguments so the first argument
is going to be the batch size i want to
be able to pass the batch size to
as an argument to my generators and also
i'm going to pass the train train
data path
the validation data path and also the
test data
path
so as you can guess we're going to
create
generators for each part of our data set
so the first thing we're going to do is
create a preprocessor
so
let me just define it here
so this preprocessor is going to
basically be used in order to
pre-process our data before it's fed to
our deep learning model
so for this we're going to use a class
from tensorflow which is the
image data generator class so let me
just
import it here first
so
from
tensorflow
that
keras that
preprocessing
that image
import
image data generator
and here we're gonna be using this image
data generator
so i'm gonna call
my
class here
[Music]
and
here in fact if you look at this class
image data generator you're gonna see
that you have
many different transformations that you
can apply
for now let's just not worry too much
about them for now i just want to focus
on one thing which is the rescale
parameter and the rescale parameter is
gonna basically rescale our data so it's
going to rescale our images and here
what i want to do is
choose a value that will be multiplied
with our data set so that it's rescaled
so i want basically to divide the values
of my
pixels by 255 which is the maximum
possible value
in rgb images so here i'm just going to
choose 1
over
255
and what this means is that
i want my preprocessor to be used i'll
show you in a minute how we're going to
use it but i want it to be used to
pre-process my images before they are
passed through
my deep learning model
so here i'm going to create my
generators so i have
i need three generators so train
generator
is going to be the first one
and for this i'm just gonna use my
preprocessor
and i'm gonna use a utility function
called flow
from
directory
so this is a very helpful function that
you can use
and in fact what it does is that
it takes a path to your folder so for
example for the trained data we're gonna
do
uh
that
or sorry what did i call it train data
path
so train
data path
and then what it's going to do is just
going to look at our
folder
so for example for the train
data path folder and you're just going
to look at all the folders that exist
within that directory and it's gonna
suppose that each folder contains
images that belong to one class so that
specific class
so
this means that our generator is gonna
automatically know that all of the
images belong that exists inside this
folder belong to the same class same
thing for this folder and for the other
folders as well so this is going to help
us immensely we don't need to
specifically build the data set where we
say
this image has this label in fact with
this utility function tensorflow is
going to help us do that automatically
so
other
parameters that we need to give to this
utility function as the
class mode
so for the class mode i'm gonna use
categorical
and for the
target size i'm gonna use 60
by
60
so this means that i want all of my
images to be resized to 60 by 60 and for
the categorical
as i mentioned it in the first tutorial
if we use categorical here we have to
also use categorical cross entropy when
we are compiling our model we can also
use
uh
sparse let me just check here if it's
maybe uh
shown here class mode one of it's either
categorical binary or sparse so if we
use sparse then we need to use
uh sparse
labels if we choose categorical then
this means that our labels need to be
one heart encoded
so let's look at the next
parameter so here we're gonna choose
color mode to be
rgb because my images are colored images
uh also there is a parameter called
shuffle that i want to set to true this
means that
in each epoch
or in each batch
my images will be shuffled so that
between two epochs basically the order
of the images will not be the same this
kind of
uh
randomness helps our model be more
generalized and learn
features and ignore that order between
the images because we don't want our
model to learn that
and finally the batch size we're gonna
give it the batch size which we are
passing here as a parameter
so this will be for the train generator
and we're going to be doing exactly the
same thing for the validation set and
for
the test set the only thing that's going
to change is
the
the path and maybe for the test set we
can set this to false because we don't
need
we don't need to shuffle the data when
we're just testing so let me do this
quickly now
[Music]
so i have finished
creating generators for my
different folders so for the test data
i'm using this approach the same thing
for the validation set and for the test
set
and as i mentioned the only difference
is that for the validation set of course
i'm using the
validation images for the test set the
test images
and i'm just returning these generators
here i also
set shuffle to false for validation and
for test because it doesn't matter that
much for when we're validating on or
when we're testing our model whether we
have
that basically a
randomness or not that randomness
matters much more when we're doing the
training which is why we're setting
shuffle to true for the train generator
so now we have our generators ready what
we need to do now is to
use our function so that we have our
data set ready in order to
start training our deep learning model
so let's instantiate first our
generators
and here let me just
maybe
deactivate this part of my code because
i don't need it
of course you don't have to always
follow what i'm doing here you can just
remove these parts because
we don't need them anymore so we split
the data we ordered to test
the test set so we don't need this these
parts but for now i'm just going to keep
them i might delete them next but they
will not have any effect on what we're
going to add here
so
first i need to import
my
function that creates generators and
then i have to use
i have to set the paths to my
train and validation folders so they
will be
these folders here so
let me just put this here
in fact let's just delete these
they're not they're just going to be
taking some space
and here since i have
the train
folder the validation folder i only need
to add the
path
to
test
and here i'm just gonna maybe change the
name so that
because we're not gonna be saving
anything in these folders
and here i'm gonna set it to my test
folder
so my test folder is
this one so i'm gonna copy this path
[Music]
paste it
then
i'm just gonna
add my
backward slashes here
so now we have all of our three pads
and i can use my
create generators
function and it's going to take a batch
size let me maybe set a batch size here
so
i'm going to choose a batch size of 64.
now this is also again another parameter
you can play with you can choose
different values i recommend you choose
something like
you know a multiplied number of two so
you choose for example 2 4 8
16 32 64 so on and so forth
and here i'm going to keep it
64 and you might face a problem sometime
when the
batch size is too large for example
let's say you choose 512
maybe the training will not start and
you're gonna get an error where it says
oom which means out of memory which
means that you don't have enough memory
to load all of those images at once so
if you face that error i i suggest you
decrease this number here and it should
work fine
so
let's go here and pass
our
parameters so
path
to
train
that to well and path to
test
and of course let's go to our function
just to check we're going to get these
as outputs so let me maybe just copy
them so that we can go quickly here
so now with this i can generate
my or i can create my generators using
the images that exist in these paths
here
and with this we can now pass these
generators to our deep learning model so
that we can
train the model
first we're gonna create our deep
learning model architecture so for that
we're gonna
use our
street signs model here
street science model and the street
science model takes the number of
classes as a parameter
so here for the number of classes we can
actually
get them using
the generators any of the generators
since the train generator is
the one that contains the most images
let me maybe just use it so
number classes equals
train generator dot num classes and then
i can pass this to my deep learning
model
and
now i have my model ready
then we need to do the same as we did in
the first tutorial tutorial so here
we're gonna first compile
our model
and to compile it we have uh several
options the first one is the
optimizer
so for now let's just
keep adam as the first tutorial
second we need to set the
loss
and here
i'm gonna use categorical
cross
entropy
and again i'm using categorical cross
entropy because
my generators here i have set the class
mode to categorical if i set this to
sparse and i set this to
and i keep this categorical then i'm
going to have
an error at the end
and
the final thing we need to define here
are the
metrics
and for that i'm just going to use the
accuracy
so
by this
by doing this we're going to have our
model compiled and what's gonna be left
now is to fit the data so here i'm gonna
do model.fit
and here we can actually
do something
uh that's that looks a little different
than the first tutorial so in the first
tutorial we had that
x and y
but in fact you can just pass the full
generator so this generator and this and
this one they all contain the
correct image
and also its corresponding label we
didn't have to explicitly do that by
when we used the
from flow from directory method it has
done this for us so we have all
generators ready so we can just pass
the train generated generator sorry as a
parameter like this
and then we can set
for example other parameters
like
the
ebox
so here we can choose whatever epochs we
want maybe i'm just gonna
add it
here so that it's easily
changed later
ebox
and also we have the batch size we're
gonna use the same batch size
and also
we gonna pass the validation images
and the validation generator here so for
that we can use the
validation
data parameter and we can pass the
valve generator
as the argument
so here as you can see we didn't have to
specifically mention the images and
their labels
separately like we did in the mnist
example so here in the amnest we had the
x strain contains the images the y train
contains the labels but in this case
here we didn't need to do that because
our generator takes care of that there's
already the images and their
corresponding labels so with this we can
fit our data and we can train our deep
learning model
and this would be almost uh
almost identical to what we did before
apart from the generators and i
mentioned in the previous tutorial that
there are some things that we need to do
when we're building a project like this
so for example one of the important
things would be to save your model save
the best model during training so i'm
going to show you how to do this now
so in order to save the best model
during training we're going to use
something
in tensorflow that's called callbacks
and
these callbacks are actually
functions that are called during the
training
and
basically they do whatever you want them
to do specifically we want to save the
best model so we're going to use a
callback that saves the best model
so in order to do that we're gonna be
using some
some modules or some
classes from tensorflow so here i'm
gonna do
from tensorflow.keras.covacs
i'm gonna import
a callback called
model checkpoint
so here i'm going to use this one
here i'm going to give it a name
so for example
we can call it
checkpoint saver so kpt
saver and i'm gonna instantiate that
class so model checkpoint and then i'm
gonna pass
a set of parameters to my class
so here
the first thing we need to give it is a
path to where we want our model to be
saved so path
to save
model
and let me maybe define it
right here so path to save
model
and i just want to save it in the same
directory
i want to
create a directory called data
and
or maybe just
models
and that will be it so i'm gonna be
saving my
model inside a directory here that will
be called models
and
then i need to give other parameters to
my callback
so one thing would be the
monitor
and here i'm going to give it
the valve
accuracy
so what this
parameter is going to do
so this parameter here monitor is
basically going to well monitor this
value here
and what we wanted to do is that
we wanted to follow this mode
so here i'm going to set it to max which
means that
i want my
basically my program to save the model
whenever i get a validation accuracy
that is higher than the previous
saved accuracy
and this is why i'm setting here max
because it's going to be
my model is going to be looking at the
validation accuracy and whenever it gets
a little higher
then it's going to save it
if it gets lower then we don't do
anything we keep the same
model that was saved before
and
why we're sending here
max is specifically for the reason that
i just mentioned which is we need
to basically only save the models that
have higher validation accuracy if for
example i had here
to monitor validation loss
then i would be using the min mode
because
for the validation loss the
less it becomes the better my model
would become so i only want to save my
model when this validation accuracy
becomes lower hence the mode min
so for me i want to monitor the
validation accuracy the higher it gets
the the program will save it
so that's why i'm setting to validation
accuracy and the mode to max
and also
there is a parameter called saved best
only
i'm gonna set it to true so i only want
to i only want the best to to be saved
which means that i'm only going to have
one model to be saved
which means that if i had a validation
accuracy i save a
model for that validation accuracy if a
new model has better validation accuracy
then i'm gonna replace the previous
model
uh if i set this to false then i'm gonna
keep the previous model and save the new
one
next to it so for me i just want to save
the best one so i'm going to set this
parameter to true
and also
we can choose a frequency of saving
so
here i'm going to set it to epoch so
we're only going to look at the the
validation accuracy at the end of the
epoch and only then we can choose
whether to save the
uh parameter the model or not
and finally
i'm just going to set verbose to
1 which is just
helps us for debugging purposes to see
when the model
has been saved or not
so now i have my callback ready and
to use the this callback what you need
to do is to add
a
parameter here called callbacks to the
fit function
and here you can give it a list of
callbacks so for now we only have one
which is the checkpoint
saver so i'm going to pass it here if we
had other callbacks then we can also
pass them here as part of the list but
we're not gonna do this unless as i
mentioned we have another callback and
speaking of callbacks i also want to
show you another
interesting callback that you can use
which we can also import from the
callbacks
module here and it's called
early stopping
so
this uh callback here what it does is
that we can set
some number of epochs
that according to these this number of
epochs if my model does not improve then
i'm just gonna stop the training
so this could be useful when you're
training for
a
large number of epochs and maybe for
let's say 30 or 50 epochs your model
does not improve at all so it's better
to just stop the training
so here how to use this is almost the
same way we
use the model checkpoint callback so
we're going to have to
instantiate the class so i'm going to
call it early stop
and i'm going to use the class early
stopping
i'm going to monitor something so here
i'm going to choose to monitor the
validation accuracy
just like i did for the model checkpoint
and also i need to set the patients so
here for example i can set the patients
to 10
so what this means is that
i'm telling my
my program here that if after 10 epochs
my validation accuracy does not go
higher then just stop the training
so for example i might i might use
let's say
let's let's say
100 epochs
and after 10 epochs we reach certain
validation accuracy and at the 20th
epoch the validation accuracy does not
go higher so that means the model did
not improve in that case i'm just going
to stop the training before continuing
the rest of the 80 epochs
so this could be a very useful and
different
scenarios and we're using it here and in
order to tell our model to basically use
this callback we need to pass it
as
part of the list of callbacks here
so now we have
our
program ready and we can fit the data to
our model and we can save
the
the model
inside a folder here called
models and we have everything ready so
with this
let us test our model let me clear the
terminal i'm gonna run python
stream
in fact i just noticed that actually my
script is called stree instead of street
signs so let me just
quickly
modify this
so street signs example
and now let me
call it or let me
call my
script from here so street
signs example
so let's run this
and see what we get
hopefully we don't have any errors
so as you can see from the logs uh when
you when you're using generators also
gives you an idea about number of images
that are using that are being used so
since we have trained validation and
tests this is for the number of trained
images this is for the validation this
is for the test and we also have 43
classes
and as you can see the training has
started
and
our script is working
properly so now this might take some
time since it's 15 epochs i'm going to
wait for it
until it
it finishes and then we're gonna look at
our
uh saved model and maybe i'm gonna come
back before it even finishes just to
show you that there was a model saved
here
after the first epoch
so here after
the end of the first epoch as you can
see
we reached this validation accuracy
but the most important part for us now
is that there's this
line here that says validation accuracy
improved from minus infinity to 0.4
so
this means that
our validation accuracy has improved
this means that we're going to save the
model to this folder here and as you can
see this folder was automatically
created and if we go inside of it we see
these files here and these files
actually represent our model so we have
this file we have these
two folders so this folder contains the
weights and
this
all of the
elements that exist inside this folder
represent our model
so now each time it's
improved
it's gonna be saved in the same place
here and for now i'm just gonna wait
until the training is done and then i'll
show you how
how to use that final model to evaluate
the
test set for example and to do other
things
so now the training has finished it
didn't take that long
and at the end you see that in different
uh epochs
whenever the accuracy
the validation accuracy became higher we
saved the model so now we're sure that
this folder here contains the best model
that was saved during the training
and now that we have this
we can use our model
in order to evaluate the data sets and
this could be done easily using also
some tensorflow utilities so for example
since we don't need this part here
i can just
for example said this
and this is also something that
sometimes i do
which is to
uh basically set what i call switchers
so train
i'm gonna use i'm gonna set it to false
because i'm not training
and i would do this whenever
i'm doing part of the code that i know i
might use it
again so i set it to
this switch switcher here
and i can set it to true or false
depending on what i want
and
for example
i can set this
test to
true and then my
part of the code that does the testing
will be added here so if
test
so if test
then
if i am using this switch then i want to
use my model that was saved in order to
evaluate my
data set
so now that we have
uh
our model here we can use some
[Music]
tensorflow utilities in order to load
our model
so here for example
i can call my model
and load it using tf dot
keras
actually i don't think i have
okay
import tensorflow as tf i did not import
tensorflow in this module here so
tf.keras.models
dot
load
model
and here i can give it a path to my
model so
my model is saved in this path here so
whenever i call my script it's going to
find it
it's right next to it and then what i
can do is
for example
maybe i might be i can
[Music]
basically print my model's architecture
and the most important thing is that we
can use the model to
evaluate
the set the sets that we have so i want
to evaluate my model on the validation
set and on the test set so we can also
do this very easily
here by passing the
generator directly
and
maybe
i can add a print here
evaluating
validation set
and
evaluating
test set
and here
i'm gonna call
model.evaluate on my test
generator
so
let's now if we run the code the
training will not start
we will only have the
ma the data
basically loaded into these generators
and then we're gonna evaluate those
generators
so here i'm gonna call my script again
everything is saved let's see if
this runs without any problems
okay again since we have the generators
it's gonna show us this
uh i don't know this is actually a
summary
okay let me save this
i'm gonna run the script again
hopefully there are no more
errors
let's see
okay the architecture
is here
and then the evaluation has started
so now it finished evaluating the
validation set which is 99
percent accuracy 99.67 to be exact and
on the test set
we'll see how much it is so on the test
set we see that we get an accuracy of
96.81
which is not too bad it's really good
so this means that
by training our model on
these uh images here
and by testing them on the test set that
we organized
these images were never seen by our
model
and it still
achieved a very high accuracy of 96.81
so
now you know how to basically train your
model and also how to evaluate it let's
see what we can do next
so what i would like to show you now are
maybe some things that you can do to
improve the results even more
because
when you're doing machine learning or
deep learning you're going to be doing
lots of experimentation and your goal
will be to always improve this test
accuracy this is the most important
metric for you
when of course when you're doing a
task such as classification if you have
a different task for example object
detection then maybe your metric will be
mean average precision for example
but here since we have classification we
want to improve this accuracy even more
if we can
so
i want to show you some
few techniques that you can do in order
to try to improve the results
the first ones are just by
basically doing lots of experimentation
by changing these
values here so for example you can train
for longer i've only used 15 epochs
maybe you can go
longer 30 50 even 100 epochs and see if
that can improve the model
you can change the batch size you can
also
change your deep learning model
architecture you can add few layers
remove few layers you can change these
numbers of
filters here
you can for example experiment with
global average pooling you can maybe
remove this and add flatten layer
instead and see how all of this can
affect your results
so
as you can see you have a lot
of things that you can experiment with
and also
this is from a maybe a model perspective
but from a data perspective you can also
do a few things so for example here
you have the generator
and we're using this image
data generator class and in fact inside
this class you have several data
augmentation techniques so data
augmentation techniques can help a lot
in avoiding overfitting and it can also
give your accuracy a bit of a notch and
so that you can get maybe a few points
more
and for example if you're going to
follow this path
then i want to mention something
important here so
so far we created only one preprocessor
that we use for train validation and
test
but
this is because the only thing we're
doing now is scaling so
if we're scaling the images for the
train set we need to do it for the
validation set and the test set but if
you start adding
other
data augmentation techniques for example
let's say
let me just check here
shift
or maybe let me just read a little bit
here
what can we use i think there's
rotation range
for example and rotation range for
example you can choose
i think it's
in degrees so you can choose for example
10 degrees this means that your images
will be
uh
will be rotated between 10 and -10
degrees
uh you can add
other things like
shift or maybe width shift range yeah
so this is to shift your image a little
bit
uh from left to right just a little bit
and you can give it
a
small
amount for example
let's say
0.1 which means 10
so i want like my image to be shifted 10
to the left and 10 to the right
and between these two so it can be like
5 3
this is uh going to be used as a range
and you can do all sorts of other
uh data augmentation techniques
so the first thing that i want to
basically emphasize here is that if
you're using
this as preprocessor you shouldn't use
it for
validation and for the test set and the
reason for this is that
the validation and test sets
basically represent
the
sets that your model were in your model
where will encounter in real life so in
real life
uh it's not necessarily you're not
necessarily gonna have these shifts
because these are synthetic
augmentations
in real life you want to test only on
real images
but when you're training
you can do all sorts of these
augmentation techniques
so
in order to avoid this you should
always create two uh
two preprocessors for example you can
call this train preprocessor
and you can
for example add another one you can call
it
test preprocessor for the test
preprocessor you remove these
you only leave the scaling part because
it's necessary if you scale the train
set then you have to apply the same
thing for the validation and the test
sets but then you can use this
preprocessor
for the training part and this
for
[Music]
the validation and the test generators
so this is how you would do it and this
could also bring
some improvements to your model
so just make sure you follow this kind
of methodology when you're
doing these different data advancation
things
and
apart from this
as you can see you have several things
you can do you can add more augmentation
you can change
you can even change the target size
maybe
use 40 by 40 or 80 by 80 see if that can
improve the results or not
so i definitely
recommend and i urge you to
experiment with this and see if you can
beat this accuracy which is 96.81
and this is gonna help you
basically learn more and it's gonna
show you the power of deep learning
sometimes just by changing a small
parameter you can get a large
improvement
and then
one last thing i want to show you also
in terms of things you can improve
for example here for the optimizer i
have
passed it as a string because this is
one possibility to do it another one
would be to
create an optimizer here
and you can use
tf.keras dot
the optimizers let me check
so tf
optimizers
and here
you can call for example the optimizer
adam
and
this is something that you can find in
the documentation so tf keras optimizers
so the documentation can be very very
helpful when you're
working with tensorflow they have lots
of examples they have lots of uh
of
tutorials that you can use
for your projects
and here so what i wanted to show you is
that if you
use the
adam optimizer like this then you have
the option to pass some parameters to it
so here if we go to the documentation
you see that you can pass the learning
rate for example which is very important
parameter in deep learning
these parameters here
i usually don't touch
but for the learning rate i
do lots of experimentations with it
because i have seen that
it can have
great
effect on your model so here
for example you can
add learning rate
so lr for learning rate
let's say
0.02
uh so this 10 to the power of -4
and then i can pass this as
my
parameter here
r let me check just if this is the
correct way to call the parameter yeah
learning rate
and then i can pass it here and then you
can this is another hyper parameter for
you that you can play with and see if
you can improve the results and then the
way you would do it is that you can pass
this optimizer
here like so
so this is also something that i wanted
to show you
just for the adam optimizer you see you
can play with the learning rate
value here and also since we're talking
about atom optimizer just a quick note
you see here that there is this last
parameter called or this parameter
called ams grad and it's by default set
to false this is actually a variation of
the adam optimizer
i've read a little bit the paper
that showed this technique and they
showed that in some cases adam actually
fails to converge and by converging i
mean it fails to
basically get the loss function to go
very low and in those cases in many of
those cases ams grad can help so for
example you can also
if you're using adam for your
deep learning task and you see that the
loss function is not
going down
then maybe one thing you can experiment
with is to set the
ams
grad
to true and you can test with this
variation of adam optimizer so as you
can see you have a lot and a lot of
things that you can do but just
this
this set of parameters and this set of
techniques that i mentioned now can help
you improve the accuracy by a large
margin
so when you're done training and
evaluating your model
what you basically
need to do at the end is
to
use that model in your application it
could be a web app web application it
could be a mobile application or an
embedded application
and for that what you would usually do
is uh use this standalone script that
just loads your model and for example it
takes a path to an image as a parameter
and it gives you a prediction on that
image so this is what i'm going to show
you now so
let's create a new script and i'm going
to call it for example
predictor dot by
let me just maybe choose my predictor
dot phi
in this example what i want to do is uh
to show you
how we can just load an image load our
model and make a prediction with our
model on that image
so let me maybe start here by defining
this part here
and
i want to basically
have a pad to my image
let me call it maybe image path
and what i would like to have is some
sort of a function
called predict
with model and this function would take
image
it would take the image path
um maybe it would take my
model and image path and it would return
to me the correct prediction
so it would be something like this
so now let me define this function here
and
maybe let's start defining it here and
maybe later move it to the utility
script
so define
predict
with
model
and it's going to take model and
image path
so here what i want to do is
to first
load the load that image and then use my
model to predict on that image
so
first thing uh the first
approach i'm going to use is by
using purely tensorflow functions so let
me import
tensorflow
stf here
i'm going to use
my
tensorflow import here to
load my image
so i'm going to use here or create a
variable called image
tf dot
io dot
read file
[Music]
and i'm going to give it my
image path here
so this is
a utility function that's going to help
us load this image and save it
inside this variable called image and
then
i want to
basically decode my image
tf dot
image dot
decode
png since
all of my images
are
png images
so here i'm gonna
do this
decode as png
so i'm gonna decode my image
and then i need to choose the number of
channels since it's an rgb image i'm
gonna choose three
then what i'm gonna do is
basically rescale my image
and in order to do that i'm gonna use a
utility function also so i'm gonna do
image equals
tf dot image dot convert
image d type
and
i'm gonna give it my
image as a parameter here i'm gonna
choose the type to be
tf dot float 32
so in fact just by doing this
during this part of the
of the code here
i'm reading the file reading the image
using this read file method i'm decoding
it since it's a png image i'm using
decode png and then by using this
function here here convert image d type
it's going to convert my
image
pixels since now they are unsigned
integers in eight bits it's gonna
turn them into a float32
uh type and also it's gonna scale them
by
turning the pixel values between 0 and 1
instead of 0 and 255
so without even mentioning here the
scale value by saying for example divide
by 255 this function is going to do it
for us
and you can check that by going to the
documentation regarding this function
here
after that i'm going to have to resize
my image so i'm going to use tf
dot image dot
resize
and i'm going to give it my image and
then a list of the width and height
and here i'm choosing 60 by 60 because
as you remember
in the generators here or in the flow
from directory we are
using target size 60 by 60 which means
that all of our images are resized to 60
by 60 so we need to keep that same order
when
reading an image
to pass it through our model
so here we have resized our image
and last we need to
basically expand
dimensions of my
tensor and here i'm going to give it my
image and axis 0.
so just to explain what this does in
fact at this level here we can have
a shape of 60 by 60 by 3
but
by doing this by expanding the
dimensions we're going to get a shape of
1
by
60 by 60 by 3.
and this is the format that our model
is expecting our images to be in so let
me check here as you can see the input
layer expects none then 60 by 60 by 3
and this none can be anything
but there needs to be this dimension
here so if we're using one image to pass
it to our model we need to set that
first value to one to say that this is
one image of size 60 by 60 by 3 and then
our input layer will not complain
because
this
this basically
follows the same
shape that we defined during the
training
and then once we have our image ready
what we can do is call
our model predict function and we're
gonna pass the image to it
so this is gonna give us a list of
probabilities
of
that image belonging to one of the
one of the classes so here i'm going to
save my
predictions
to this variable here
so you can choose this function to
return
the list of probabilities
maybe you want to
to use this
for
maybe
using some threshold to say that this is
acceptable or not so at this stage here
for example you might get
0.005
for the first class
0.003 for the second class then you
might you may you might get
0.99 for the
uh
class here the third class and then also
the rest will be
zero zero point something and for the
rest of the other classes as well
so this means that
our model if we get a result like this
and our model thinks that this image
most likely belongs to class three or
class two because our folders
as you remember they start from zero so
we start from class zero if we go to the
third class it's actually two
so if we do if we run this command and
we get
this
list here then this means that our model
thinks that this image belongs to
this class here
so what we want is
uh basically to get only that class and
we don't want to get probabilities at
least for me that's what i want to do
but for you feel free to maybe return
this
list here and then do whatever you want
with it but for me since i just want to
return the exact class that we got
i'm gonna do
[Music]
predictions equals
numpy dot
in fact
we can give it
my predictions here
and let me just import numpy
in port
numpy s and p
so
what this is going to give me is the
index of the max value which is exactly
what i want so in this case for example
it would return
let me just maybe do it
in a comment here
it would give me
2 because
2 is the index of the max value
0.99
and then i'm just gonna return
my
predictions
so now we have our function ready and
here let's choose for example
one of the
images
in the test set
let's choose this for example
and copy as path so that we can quickly
do that
i'm just going to paste it here
i'm going to add the backwards slashes
here
quickly
and then
of course i need to load my model so
just like we did
here
we can load our model
by using this command here
so the model
exists in this folder called models
so we're going to be able to find it
from our script mypredictor.pi i'm going
to pass it
to our function predict with model and
then we're gonna get
the
corresponding class and then here i'm
just gonna
print something like
okay i'm gonna use an f string
prediction
[Music]
equals
prediction
so
let's run our script and see what we can
get let me clear this first python
my predictor.buy and just do one last
look here
see hopefully we have no
errors
okay well the first prediction was
actually uh wrong so this prediction it
says this this is class 12 but it
actually
is class 2. let's test with
other images as well
so here for example i added this
image here from the test set
which which should give us the
label 0
so let's run our
predictor.buy
and here as you can see we get the
correct result is zero i know
i know that the correct result is zero
because i'm just looking at the
corresponding folder here
so
we got the wrong result for this one the
correct one for this one
but this is basically
this is not a way to test the model the
best way to test the model is by doing
evaluation as we did before but this is
just to show you how you would use
your deep learning model
to
predict on images
in a standalone application so as you
can see here we have an application
this could be easily embedded in
any sort of application web app or
mobile app or whatever
and basically we just have a function
that reads the image uses the model and
makes prediction with it and then you
get that prediction and you can do
whatever you want with it
so now you have seen how
to use your model in a standalone
application in order to make predictions
on
specific images
so just a quick recap of what we've seen
in this last part
so basically we used a german traffic
signs data set that was collected
and we had real life images
we explored that data set we prepared
the training validation and test sets we
built a neural network the functional
way
we also created data generators we added
callbacks to our fit method
we trained and evaluated our model
and we discussed some potential
improvements that we can do to get
better results for example data
augmentation
we also finished that part by
by running inference on single images
and building standalone examples on how
you would use your model
so if you have any questions regarding
what we have covered so far then please
feel free to contact me on
my social media accounts so i have
linkedin account and also twitter
account
and if you're interested in
a free machine learning job ready
checklist which is a checklist that i
put together based on my experience
working on machine learning projects in
the computer vision industry
then please check the link below there
will be only one link but it's going to
point you to all the necessary
information
regarding my
social media accounts and also this free
checklist